ASSEMBLY MEMBER REAVIS NOTICES
THE ABSENCE OF A QUORUM THE
SERGEANTS AT ARMS WILL PREPARE
THE CHAMBER AND BRING IN THE
ABSENT MEMBERS THE CLERK WILL
CALL THE ROLL. AGUIAR-CURRY.
ARAMBULA BOB HAN BERMAN BIGELOW
BLOOM BOERNER HORVATH BONTA
GROW BURKE CALDERON CORREO
CERVANTES CHAU GEN DAVID CHIU
CHOI CANSON TO COOLEY COOPER
CUNNINGHAM DALY DALY DEEP
EGGMAN FLORA FONG FRAZIER
FRIEDMAN A REAL. GALLAGHER
CRISTINA GARCIA EDUARDO GARCIA
GIPSON GLORIA GONZALEZ GRAY
GRAYSON HOLDEN IRWIN JONES
SAWYER KALRA KAMLAGER KILEY
LACKEY LEVINE LIMON LOW
MAIENSCHEIN MATHIS MAYES
MCCARTY MEDINA MULLIN
MURATSUCHI NAZARIAN OBERNOLTE
O'DONNELL PATTERSON
PETRIE-NORRIS QUIRK QUIRK SILVA.
RAMOS REYES THREE OF US ROBERT
RIVAS RODRIGUEZ RUBIO SALAS
SANTIAGO SMITH STONE TEEN
VOEPEL WALDRON WEBER WICKS WOOD
MISTER SPEAKER.
MEMBERS OF A
QUORUM IS PRESENT WE ASK OUR
GUESTS AND VISITORS IN THE REAR
OF THE CHAMBER AND IN THE
GALLERY TO PLEASE STAND FOR THE
PRAYER. THE DAYS PRAYER WILL BE
OFFERED BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GABRIEL. LAST WEDNESDAY
AFTERNOON I RECEIVED THE CALL.
SOMEONE OUT OF THE BLUE I JOIN
THE FAMILY FACE TIME WHERE MY
FATHER SHARED DISTURBING NEWS.
AFTER COMPLAINING FOR SEVERAL
MONTHS OF PERSISTENT NECK PAIN
AN MRI HAD REVEALED CONCERNING
ABNORMALITIES. BASED ON THE MRI
AND OTHER SYMPTOMS THE DOCTORS
RAISED THE PROSPECT OF A RARE
AND HIGHLY DEADLY FORM OF
METASTATIC BLOOD AND BONE
CANCER WITH AN EXPECTED
SURVIVAL RATE. THAT LEFT US
BREATHLESS IN A MOMENT MY WORLD
WAS TURNED UPSIDE DOWN. PRIOR
TO THE CALL MY AFTERNOON HAD
BEEN FILLED WITH THE TYPICAL
FRUSTRATIONS AND ANNOYANCES
THAT TOO OFTEN MARK END OF
SESSION IN THE LEGISLATURE.
DISTRACTIONS FROM THE REAL AND
URGENT WORK OF SERVING THE
PEOPLE. IN THE MY AFTER THE
CALL ALL OF THAT MELTED AWAY.
WE ARE APPROACHING THE SEASON
THE HIGH HOLIDAYS WHICH WILL BE
CELEBRATED BY COMMUNITIES IN
CALIFORNIA ISRAEL AND AROUND
THE WORLD. IN WAYS SUBTLE AND
OBVIOUS THE HIGH HOLIDAYS- JUST
TO CONSIDER OUR MORTALITY. TO
CONFRONT THE INESCAPABLE
REALITY THAT OUR TIME ON THIS
PLANET IS FINITE. THE
CONFRONTATION WITH OUR OWN
INEVITABLE DEATH IS NOT MEANT
TO SCARE US BUT RATHER TO
ENCOURAGE THE DIFFICULT WORK OF
REFLECTION AND INTROSPECTION.
TO HELP US ASK OURSELVES THE
TOUGH QUESTIONS. ARE WE LIVING
THE LIFE WE INTENDED. ARE WE
BEING TRUE TO OURSELVES ARE WE
SPENDING OUR PRECIOUS TIME AND
ENERGY ON WHAT REALLY MATTERS.
WITH LUCK WE WILL COME OUT OF
THE HIGH HOLIDAYS WITH A
RENEWED SENSE OF PURPOSE AND
PERSPECTIVE. WE WILL LAY DOWN
OLD GRIEVANCES SET ASIDE
NEEDLESS DISTRACTIONS AND
REFOCUS ON THAT WHICH IS MOST
DESERVING OF OUR TIME AND
TALENTS AND ENERGY. OVER THE
PAST SEVERAL DAYS MY DAD HAS
BEEN SUBJECT TO A BATTERY OF
BLOOD TESTS AND SCANS. MY
FAMILY HASN'T TOWARD SLEEPLESS
NIGHTS AND EXTREME FEAR.
SOMEHOW BY THE INCREDIBLE GRACE
OF GOD THE RESULTS OF THOSE
TESTS HAVE SURPRISED HIS
DOCTORS AND DELIGHTED OUR
FAMILY. GONE IS THE SHADOW OF
CANCER REPLACED BY DIAGNOSIS OF
AILMENTS THAT WHILE DIFFICULT
ARE FAR LESS SCARY. WE HAVE
STEPPED BACK FROM THE ABYSS.
HELLO HELLO HELLO HELLO TENOVER
IN MONTANA ARE GOD AND GOD OF
OUR ANCESTORS. AS WE APPROACH
THE FINAL DAYS OF A DIFFICULT
SESSION MAY WE BE GRANTED THE
PERSPECTIVE AND INSIGHT TO
DECIPHER WHAT REALLY MATTERS.
TO SEPARATE THE HOLY WORK OF
PUBLIC SERVICE FROM THE
DISTRACTIONS OF PETTY POLITICS.
TO SEE THE BEST IN EACH OTHER.
TO APPRECIATE THE PASSION OF
OUR COLLEAGUES STAFF
CONSTITUENTS IN ADVOCATES
INCLUDING THOSE WITH WHOM WE
MAY NOT ALWAYS AGREE. TO RISE
ABOVE THE NOISE AND FOCUS ON
THE IMMENSE PRIVILEGE WE HAVE
BEFORE US THE OPPORTUNITY TO
MAKE LAWS THAT CAN UPLIFT OUR
COMMUNITIES ADVANCINGJUSTICE
AND HEAL OUR WORLD. TO RECALL
WITH CLARITY WHY WE ARE HERE
AND WHAT WE ARE FIGHTING FOR.
IN MAY WE ARE TIRED CAPITAL
COMMUNITY AND ALL HUMANKIND BE
GRANTED THE ULTIMATE BLESSINGS
OF GOOD HEALTH. A MAN. THANK
YOU FOR REMEMBER GABRIEL WE ASK
OUR GUESTS AND VISITORS TO
REMAIN STANDING AND JOIN US FOR
THE FLAG SALUTE PLEASE JOIN
ASSEMBLY MEMBER SALAS HE LEADS
US IN THE LOOP. READY. TO
SALUTE PLEDGE. I ALLEGIANCE TO
THE FLAG. A FORMER. THANK YOU
MAY BE SEATED. MOVING TO THE
READING OF THE PREVIOUS DAY'S
JOURNAL ASSEMBLY GERMAN
SACRAMENTO THURSDAY JUNE
ELEVENTH TWENTY TWENTY THE
CINEMATIC NINETY AMAZON WILL
KEVIN MULLIN SPEAKER PRO
TEMPORE. AND MISS WALDRON
SECONDS THAT THE READING THE
PREVIOUS JOURNAL BE DISPENSED
WITH. PRESENTATIONS AND
PETITIONS THERE ARE NONE
INTRODUCTION AND REFERENCE OF
BILLS WILL BE DEFERRED. REPORTS
OF COMMITTEES WILL BE DEEMED
READ AND AMENDMENTS DEEMED
ADOPTED. MESSAGES FROM THE
GOVERNOR THERE ARE NONE
MESSAGES FROM THE SENATE THERE
ARE NONE. LIVING TO MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS FOR TODAY'S
ABSENCES. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
FRAZIER AND ASSEMBLY MEMBER
VOEPEL FOR MEDICAL EVEN
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WORKS FOR
MATERNITY LEAVE.
MISTER
CALDERON YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR
MISSIONS. THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER I REQUEST UNANIMOUS
CONSENT TO SUSPEND ASSEMBLY
WILL FORTY FIVE POINT FIVE TO
ALLOW ASSEMBLYMEMBERS KILEY
COOPER AG WE ARE CURRY FRIEDMAN
AND SALAS TO SPEAK ON THE
GERMAN MEMORY TODAY WITHOUT
OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE THE
ORDER I REQUEST UNANIMOUS
CONSENT TO SUSPEND ASSEMBLY
RULE SEVENTY FOUR D. TO ALLOW
ASSEMBLY MEMBER JONES OR TO
TAKE UP ITEM NUMBER TEN H. I
WANNA FIVE TODAY ON THIRD
READING. WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH
SHALL BE THE ORDER. MOVING TO
BUSINESS ON THE DAILY FILE
SECOND READING THE CLERK WILL
READ. SENATE BILL FOR SEVENTY
NINE AND SENATE BILL SEVEN
THIRTY ONE. ALL BILL SEVENTEEN
READ AND AMENDMENTS ADOPTED.
YEAH MOVING TO CONCURRENCE FILE
ITEM THREE AB TWELVE OH FIVE
THE CLERK WILL READ. ASSEMBLY
BILL TWELVE OH FIVE BY SIN
REMEMBER LIMON ACCOLADE THE
CALIFORNIA CUT FLOWER
COMMISSION AND THEN YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK. BY THE
CALIFORNIA CUT FLOWER
COMMISSION SPORTS DECISION
INSTEAD IN STATE STATUTE TO
IVE CALIFORNIA FLOWER FARMERS
AN OPPORTUNITY TO RECOGNIZE. TO
RE ORGANIZED THE FUTURE INSTEAD
OF RELYING ON THE MUCH LONGER
LEGISLATIVE PROCESS TO
RECONVENE RECONVENE THE
COMMISSION I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
MISTER MOON SEEING AND HEARING
NO FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS. OF THE- ALL
MEMBERS GO TO THEIR TO VOTE.
PALMERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
WHERE WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TALLY THE VOTE HIGHS FORTY
SEVEN NO ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS
ARE COMPARED IN.
I'D READ
VIOLATE FIVE TO EIGHT I EVERY
CAN ARKANSAS MOVING TO THE
ASSEMBLY THIRD READING FILE
FILE ITEM NINE WILL PASS AND
RETAIN MOVING A FILE ITEM TEN
H. R. ONE OH FIVE THE CLERK
WILL READ. HOUSE RESOLUTION ONE
FIVE BY SOME REMEMBER JONES
SAWYER RELATIVE TO VOTE BY MAIL
AND THE NOVEMBER THIRD TWENTY
TWENTY GENERAL ELECTION. MISTER
JONES ARE YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEKER.
ASSEMBLY HOUSE RESOLUTION ONE
OH FIVE. URGES THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT TO PRESERVE THEIR
OPERATIONAL CAPACITY OF THE
UNITED STATES POSTAL SERVICE
AND BY EXTENSION THE INTEGRITY
OF OUR AMERICAN DEMOCRACY. WHEN
BET MAIL IN BALLOTS PRESENT THE
ONLY SAFE OPTION TO VOTE IN THE
COMING ELECTION. MANY OF US
DON'T REMEMBER THE MODEL OF THE
U. S. POSTAL SYSTEM. THE RAIN
NEITHER SNOW. NOR RAIN NOR HEAT
NOR GLOOM OF NIGHT STAYS THESE
CURRENT THESE COURTEOUS FROM
THE SWIFT COMPLETION OF THEIR
APPOINTED ROUNDS WE PROBABLY
COULD ADD PANDEMIC. BECAUSE
NONE OF US HAVE HAD TO DIMINISH
DIMINISH CAPACITY OF US GETTING
OUR MAIL AT THIS TIME. IN
RECOGNITION OF THE CURRENT
CHALLENGES WE AS A LEGISLATOR
LEGISLATIVE BODY HAVE VOTED TO
SEND EVERY REGISTERED VOTER IN
CALIFORNIA A MAIL IN BALLOT. IN
RECOGNITION THIS DECISION WAS
MADE WITH THE HEALTH AND
WELFARE OF THE PUBLIC IN MIND
AS OUR STATE PRICE TO OVERCOME
COVERT NINETEEN. WHICH HAS
ALREADY INFECTED HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS OF CALIFORNIANS AND
IMPACTED THE LIVES OF COUNTLESS
MORE. THE DEVASTATION OF COVERT
NINETEEN HAS BEEN PARTICULARLY
HAPPY AND THE CITY OF LOS
ANGELES WHICH HAS ALREADY HAD
TO DEAL WITH NEARLY A HUNDRED
THOUSAND CASES AND APPROX ME
TWO THOUSAND FIVE HUNDRED
DEATHS. AMONG THE HARDEST HIT
HAVE BEEN THOSE OF THE LATINO
COMMUNITY WHO MADE UP ABOUT 50%
OF ALL KNOWN CASES IN LOS
ANGELES. MY OWN DISTRICT WHICH
IS LARGELY LATINO AND I HAVE
BEEN WORKING TIRELESSLY PROTECT
THEM DURING THIS PANDEMIC. THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA HAS AMPLE
EXPERIENCE WITH MAIL IN BALLOTS
WITH THE INSTRUCTION OF
ABSENTEE VOTING SINCE THE
NINETEEN TWENTIES. CALIFORNIA
VOTERS HAVE HISTORICALLY
FAVORED THE OPTION TO VOTE BY
MAIL AND SINCE NINETEEN SEVENTY
NINE TO STATE HAS ALLOWED ANY
REGISTERED VOTER REGARDLESS OF
STATUS AND CIRCUMSTANCE TO VOTE
REMOTELY IF THEY SO CHOOSE.
DURING THE MARCH TWENTY TWENTY
PRIMARY ELECTIONS AS COVERT
NINETEEN BEGAN TO AFFECT EVERY
ASPECT OF DAILY LIFE I 72% OF
VOTERS CAST THEIR BALLOT BY
MAIL. YOU CAN BE SURE IT
MATTERED THAT THEY HAD A
WORKING ANY FISSION POSTAL
SERVICE. THERE IS NO. EXCUSE
FOR THE TIMING OF POSTMASTER
GENERAL LEWIS THE JOYS
RESTRUCTURING. OF THE US POSTAL
SERVICE I NONPARTISAN
INSTITUTION THAT HAS SINCE.
SEVENTEEN SEVENTY FIVE
CERTAINLY AMERICAN PEOPLE IN
GOOD FAITH. SENSES INSTALLATION
IN MAY OF THIS YEAR TO THE
POSITION OF POSTMASTER GENERAL.
MISTER DETROIT HAS WORKED
PURPOSE FULLY TO LIMIT THE
POST. SERVICES THE POSTAL
SERVICE'S OPERATIONAL
EFFICIENCY THESE EFFORTS HAVE
INCLUDED BANNING OVERTIME AND
AFTER DELIVERY A TRIP TRIPS
REMOVING COUNTLESS MAILBOXES
THROUGHOUT THE NATION. AND
WITHDRAWING MAIL SORTING
MACHINES FROM POST OFFICES
INCLUDING SEVENTY SIX
THROUGHOUT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND EIGHTEEN IN THE
CITY OF LOS ANGELES ALONE. IN
THE NAME OF COST REDUCTION THE
POSTAL SERVICE IS BEING
SYSTEMATICALLY CRIPPLED BY AN
ADMINISTRATION DETERMINED TO
DISENFRANCHISE VOTERS WHOSE
COMMUNITIES HAVE GONE THEY
NEGLECTED UNDER ITS CARE.
INCLUDING THOSE IN MY OWN
DISTRICT AND OTHERS THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA. AS THIS IS THIS
MANTLING THE POSTAL SERVICE
THREATENS TO INHIBIT FREE AND
FAIR ELECTIONS. SO TOO HAS
BEGUN OBSTRUCTING THE LIVES
AMERICANS RELY ON PROMPT. AND
CONSISTENT DELIVERIES IN
CORRESPONDENCE FOR EXAMPLE THE
POSTAL SERVICE DELIVERS IT
ROUGHLY FOUR MILLION SHIPMENTS
A PRESCRIPTION MEDICATION.
EVERY DAY. SIX DAY OF. THE
RECIPIENTS OF THESE DELIVERIES
INCLUDE PATIENTS WITH CHRONIC
ILLNESSES THE ELDERLY AND OUR
NATION'S VETERANS. ARE WE
PREPARED TO LET THEM SUFFER FOR
THE SAKE OF COST CUTTING COSTS
OR TRULY FOR THE SAKE OF
DRIVING VOTERS AWAY. THE
CHANGES MADE AT THE POSTAL
SERVICE HAS BEEN SUPPORTED BY
UNFOUNDED CLAIMS THAT MAILING
BALLOTS LEAD TO MASSIVE BORDER
VOTER FRAUD. IN TRUTH.
RESEARCHERS HAVE AGAIN AND
AGAIN DISAPPROVE DISPROVEN THIS
CLAIM FINDING IN THE STUDY SAID
UNITED STATES HAS SEEN SEEN
EXTREMELY LOW RATES ARE FRAUGHT
THROUGHOUT ITS ELECTORAL
HISTORY THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
ITSELF HAS IMPLEMENTED NUMEROUS
SAFEGUARDS TO PREVENT ABSENTEE
VOTER FRAUD INCLUDING SIGNATURE
MATCHING AND UNIQUE BARCODES ON
EACH BALLOT RETURN ENVELOPE.
FURTHERMORE ABSENTEE BALLOTS
GIVE ORDERS AND LEVEL
FLEXIBILITY TO POLLING CENTRES
SIMPLY CANNOT MATCH MAILING
VOTING IS POWER TO THE PEOPLE
THERE IS MOM THERE IS MUCH THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT COULD LEARN
FROM THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
WE'RE MAILING VOTERS HAVE
BECOME ELECTORAL MAJORITY AND
WE'RE WE SOLVE PROBLEMS RATHER
THAN SIMPLY BREAKING THINGS
DOWN WE DON'T LIKE. WE AS
ELECTED OFFICIALS HAD TO DO
REALLY HAVE A DUTY TO PROTECT
NOT ONLY THE SANCTITY OF OUR
FREE ELECTIONS BUT ALSO TO
CONTINUE HEALTH AND EFFICIENCY
OF THE UNITED STATES POST
OFFICE WHOSE MISSION THE POSTAL
SERVICE SHALL HABITS IS BASIC
PARTISAN THE OBLIGATION TO
PROVIDE POSTAL SERVICES. TO
BIND THIS NATION. THE ME SAY IT
AGAIN BUYING THIS NATION TO
MISTER JOHNSON PERSON
EDUCATIONAL LEADER LITERACY AND
BUSINESS CORRESPONDENCE OF THE
OF THE PEOPLE AS YOUR PROVIDE
PROMPT RELIABLE AND EFFICIENT
SERVICES TO PATRONS IN ALL
AREAS. AS SHALL RENDER POSTAL
SERVICES TO ALL. ALL
COMMUNITIES. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR I. BOATS THANK YOU
MISTER JONES SAWYER MR BERMAN
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU
MADAM SPEAKER I JUST WANT TO
THANK MY COLLEAGUE FROM SOUTH
LOS ANGELES FOR TAKING A
LEADERSHIP ROLE- ON THIS
CRITICALLY IMPORTANT ISSUE I'VE
SAID TIME AND AGAIN- THAT NO
CALIFORNIANS SHOULD HAVE TO
RISK. THEIR HEALTH AND POSSIBLY
THEIR LIFE TO EXERCISE THEIR
CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHT TO VOTE-
BUT IT IN ORDER FOR THAT TO BE
THE CASE IT'S CRITICALLY
IMPORTANT. THAT OUR CIVIC
INFRASTRUCTURE- IS STRONG AND
FOR THE ELECTION IT'S
CRITICALLY IMPORTANT THAT THE
US POSTAL SERVICE. IS STRONG SO
THAT EVERYONE HAS THE ABILITY
TO VOTE SAFELY FROM HOME AND
HAVE THEIR VOICE HEARD- SO I
ENCOURAGE EVERYBODY TO VOTE ON
AYE ON H. R. ONE OH FIVE- BY
OUR MY COLLEAGUE. BECAUSE IT'S
SO IMPORTANT THAT THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT HEAR THE MESSAGE
LOUD AND CLEAR THAT WE NEED
THEM TO HELP DEFEND OUR
DEMOCRACY- AND WHAT'S HAPPENED
OVER THE PST. COUPLE OF MONTHS
IS VERY CONCERNING- AND IT'S A
BE A STRONG STATEMENT FROM THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT STANDPOINT.
TO SAY YOU KNOW WHAT WE
UNDERSTAND THAT EVERYBODY
SHOULD BE ABLE TO VOTE SAFELY-
AND- FROM THE SAFETY OF THEIR
OWN HOME AND SUPPORT THE US
POSTAL SERVICE WHICH IS
ACTUALLY ONE THE MOST POPULAR.
FEDERAL AGENCIES IRONICALLY SO
THIS IS A WIN WIN FOR
EVERYBODY- INCLUDING MOST
IMPORTANTLY NO MATTER WHETHER
YOU'RE A DEMOCRAT OR REPUBLICAN
OR NO PARTY PREFERENCE OR ANY
OTHER PARTY- IT'S TO DEFEND OUR
DEMOCRACY AND I HOPE THAT
EVERYBODY CAN BE IN AGREEMENT
THAT THAT IS SOMETHING WORTH
FIGHTING FOR. I THANK YOU VERY
MUCH I ENCOURAGE YOUR AYE VOTE
ON HR ONE OF FIVE. THANK YOU MR
BERMAN MISTER GIVE SEND YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU VERY MUCH
BOTTOM SPEAKER AND MEMBERS. I
RISE IN SUPPORT OF HR ONE OF
FIVE WHICH CALLS THE FEDERAL.
TO END THE EFFORTS TO REDUCE
VOTING BY MAIL. IT IS CALLED IT
IS WE CALL UPON THE POSTMASTER
GENERAL. TO RESTORE ALL
EQUIPMENT REMOVE THAT AFFECTS
THE CAPACITY OF THE UNITED
STATES POST OFFICE FROM DOING
ITS JOB. THAT OUR DEMOCRACY IS
THE BEDROCK OF OUR OF THIS
AMERICAN SOCIETY WE SHOULD NOT
BE DOING. ANYTHING THAT'S GOING
TO HINGED UPON THE RIGHTS OF
THE PEOPLE FROM VOTING IN THIS
UPCOMING ELECTION MAIL BALLOT
FRAUD IS A MYTH. THAT HAS
FREQUENTLY RAIDERS UGLY HEAD
AND BEEN DISPROVEN TIME AND
TIME AGAIN OUR RECENT PRIMARY
ELECTION SHOWS THAT WE HAVE- WE
HAVE MAIL IN VOTING STATEWIDE
WITHOUT ANY VOTING FRAUD WHILE
KEEPING CALIFORNIA AND DEALING
WITH A PANDEMIC AT THE SAME
TIME. REPORTS VARIES BUT
INDICATES BETWEEN TEN TO
FIFTEEN PERCENT. SLOWDOWN IN
MAIL DELIVERY SERVICES EVEN A
SMALL SLOWDOWN COULD
DRAMATICALLY AFFECT THE OUTCOME
OF THE ELECTION AND SIMPLY-
WOULD BE INEXCUSABLE IF IN FACT
THAT SHOULD HAPPEN. OUR SENIORS
DEPENDS ON THEIR PRESCRIPTION
DRUGS BEING RECEIVED BY POST
OFFICE- SO MUCH PRODUCTS COMES
THROUGH THE POSTAL SERVICE WE
CANNOT AFFORD THIS TIME TO
DIMINISH THEIR RESOURCES AND
ALSO THE SERVICES THAT THIS
POST OFFICE PROVIDES DAY IN AND
DAY OUT. IT IS A TRUSTED ARM OF
OUR GOVERNMENT AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR STRONG
AIBEL HR FIVE. THANK YOU MISTER
GIBSON MISSED SEEING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THE MATTER MISTER
JONES ARE YOU MAY CLOSE. THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR I. BOATS. STUDENTS
WHERE WOULD YOU LIKE COOPER IS
ON THE RESOLUTION I WOULD BE
HONORED TO HAVE COAUTHORS. THE
FIRST ROLE BE OPEN FOR CO
AUTHORS. CLERK WILL OPEN THE
RAW. WATERS MEMBERS THIS VOTE
IS FOR CO AUTHORS. MEMBERS THIS
IS FOR CO AUTHORS ON HR ONE OH
FIVE. BURKE WILL CLOSE THE ROLE
IN TELL YOU THAT THERE ARE
FORTY THREE CO AUTHORS ON HR
ONE OH FIVE WE WILL TAKE A ROLL
CALL VOTE ON THIS RESOLUTION
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED THIRD OF.
HOME MEMBERS GO TO DESSERT OF A.
ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE. THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE
ROLE AND TALLY THOSE EYES FORTY
FOUR NEWS HERE THE RESOLUTIONS
ADOPTED. WILL PASS AND RTAIN
ON FILE ITEM ELEVEN. MEMBERS WE
WILL TAKE A BILLS FOR PURPOSE
OF THE AMENDMENTS NOW MOVING TO
FILE ITEM TWENTY S. B. ELEVEN
FORTY SIX THE CLERK WILL READ.
SENATE BILL ELEVEN FORTY SIX
WITH A MINUTES BY SO MY MEMORY
IS MR IF YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR
PURPOSE OF AMENDMENTS. THANK
YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND MEMBERS
TODAY PRESENTING AMENDMENTS FOR
SB ELEVEN FORTY SIX. WHICH
CHAPTER OUT THE BILL WITH AB
TWENTY ONE SIXTY FIVE. THANK
YOU AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR I. BOATS. THANK. YOU
MISTRESS WITHOUT OBJECTION WE
WILL TAKE A VOICE ANYTHING ALL
IN FAVOR SAY AYE. OPPOSED SAY.
THE I. HAVE IT THE MAMMOTH
DOTTED OUT PRINT IMPACT FILE.
FILE ITEM FIFTY B. THIRD THE
CLERK WILL READ. SENATE BILL
TWO THIRTY A MINUTE BY SOME
REMEMBER DAVE CHIU. YOUR TO
YOUR RECORD FOR PURPOSES
AMENDMENTS THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER COLLEAGUES THIS IS THE
SENATE HOUSING OMNIBUS BILL
THESE ARE SIMPLE CHAPTER NOT
AMENDMENTS AND WITH THAT I
ASKED FOR I DON'T. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR WITHOUT OBJECTION
WE WILL TAKE A VOICE VOTE ON.
THESE AMENDMENTS ALL IN FAVOR
SAY AYE. ALL OPPOSE SAME. THE
I. HAVE IT THE AMENDMENTS ARE.
OUT TO PRINT AND BACK.
TO GOOD
WORK. IN A FILE ITEM SEVENTY
TWO S. B. ELEVEN THIRTY EIGHT
CLERK OR- SENATE BILL ELEVEN
THIRTY WITH A MEMBER BY SO
REMEMBER. BURKE YOU ARE FOR
PURPOSES AMENDMENTS THANK YOU
AB ELEVEN THIRTY IS BEING
AMENDED FOR THE PURPOSE OF
CHOPPING OUT AMENDMENTS AFTER
AND I. THINK YOU FOR WITHOUT
OBJECTION WE WILL TAKE A VOICE
VOTE ON THESE AMENDMENTS ALL IN
FAVOR SAY AYE. ALL OPPOSED SAY
NO. THE AYES HAVE IT THE
AMENDMENTS ADOPTED OUT TO PRINT
AND BACK TO FILE.
THE READING.
MEMBERS. YOU'RE PLEASE WE'RE
GOING TO MOVE OFF THE DAILY
FILE AND TAKE THIS MOMENT TO
TRIBUTE TRIBUTES TO THE MEMBERS
THAT ARE DEPARTING THIS FLOOR
AFTER MONDAY. SO FIRST MISLI
MON. THE MYSTERY MOUNTAIN. MR
BERMAN YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND I
RISE TO RECOGNIZE AND CELEBRATE
MY DEAR DEAR FRIEND. THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER FROM SANTA
BARBARA MONIQUE LIMON. MY
FRIENDSHIP WITH MONIQUE BEGAN
THE WAY ALL LASTING LEGISLATIVE
FRIENDSHIPS DO. SHE
UNEXPECTEDLY LAID OFF ONE OF
THE FIRST BILLS I PRESENTED. ON
THE FLOOR IN OUR FIRST YEAR
FREAKING ME OUT AND CREATING A
MAD SCRAMBLE TO GET THE BILL
OUT. NOT LONG AFTER THAT
MONIQUE TODD AND I. GOT
TOGETHER FOR DINNER ONE NIGHT
AT HAWK FARM ACROSS THE STREET.
AND THEY'VE BOTH BEEN MY BEST
YEARS EVER SINCE. MONIQUE ALL
FIVE FOOT A FEW INCHES OVER IS
AN ABSOLUTE LEGISLATIVE
POWERHOUSE. WHEN MOST OF US IN
THE CLASS OF TWENTY SIXTEEN
WE'RE STILL LEARNING THEIR
COLLEGE NAMES MONIQUE WAS
CARING BILLS TAKING ON THE OIL
INDUSTRY. NEXT AFTER RISING TO
BECOME CHAIR OF THE BANKING
COMMITTEE SHE TURNED HER SIGHTS
ON THE PAYDAY LENDING INDUSTRY
WHICH FOR YEARS. HAD ESCAPED
APPROPRIATE OVERSIGHT AND
REGULATION IN CALIFORNIA. WHEN
MONIQUE TOLD ME SHE WAS
SERIOUSLY CONSIDERING RUNNING
FOR SENATE I DID EVERYTHING I
COULD TO OUTWARDLY LOOK LIKE I
WAS BEING A SUPPORTIVE FRIEND.
WHILE SUBTLY TRYING TO
UNDERMINE AND SABOTAGE THE IDEA.
THEN ONE DAY MONIQUE AND HER
HUSBAND MIKE GOT TOGETHER WITH
ME AND MY WIFE AMY FOR LUNCH.
AS WELL AS MONIQUE LAID OUT THE
PROS AND CONS OF RUNNING ANY
WAS QUICK TO AFFIRM ALL OF THE
REASONS WHY MONIQUE SHOULD RUN.
SHE EVEN CAME UP WITH A FEW
REASONS MONIQUE HADN'T THOUGHT
OF. I REALIZE MY EFFORTS WERE
FEW DIAL IN THAT MONEY STAYS IN
THE ASSEMBLY WERE NUMBERED. THE
ASSEMBLY IS LOSS IS THE
SENATE'S GAIN. I'M GONNA MISS
SITTING NEXT TO YOU IN CAUCUS.
GRABBING CANDY ON YOUR DESK
DURING SESSION. BUMPING INTO
YOU OUTSIDE OF OUR OFFICES ON
THE SIX FOR INVENTING ABOUT
SOME OF THE MORE MAGNET
MADDENING PARTS OF OUR HOUSE.
BUT I TAKE SOLACE IN KNOWING
YOU'RE NOT GOING TO FOR. THAT
YOU'LL STILL BE AT SIX AM SPIN
CLASS WHEN WE CAN DO THAT AGAIN.
IN THAT WILL HAVE MANY MORE
MEALS TOGETHER IN THE YEARS TO
COME. AND MOST IMPORTANTLY I'M
SO HAPPY AND EXCITED FOR YOU
AND MIKE TO BECOME PARENTS.
THANK YOU MR BERMAN MITHRAS YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED ON THIS TRIBUTE.
THERE ONCE WAS A GIRL NAMED
MONIQUE. WHO LISTENED AND
OFFERED CRITIQUE. SHE LANDED
SOME ROOMMATES THAT CHANGED ALL
THEIR TRUE FACE WELL WE ALL
KNEW THAT SHE WAS UNIQUE. I'M
SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF ROOMMATES
PRESENT AND PAST FOUR SISTERS
IN THE LEGISLATURE. WE ALL
HEARD THE MOVING TRIBUTES TO
MONIQUE HER SWEETNESS WELL
BEING A BULLDOG NEGOTIATOR.
WE'VE HEARD HOW ORGANIZED SHE
IS. WE'VE HEARD HOW SHE MAKES
LISTS AND LOOKS AT ALL OPTIONS
PROS AND CONS. WE HEARD HOW
CONSIDERATE SHE IS WITH PEOPLE
AROUND HER. WE'VE HEARD SHE
STANDS UP FOR ORDINARY PEOPLE
AGAINST BIG CORPORATE INTERESTS.
WE'VE HEARD SHE STANDS UP FOR
NATURE AND THE ENVIRONMENT IN
THE OCEANS AGAINST POLLUTING
INDUSTRIES. WE'VE HEARD THAT
SHE'S ABLE TO FIND COMMON
GROUND WITHOUT COMPROMISING HER
IDEALS. WE'VE HEARD SHE'S ABLE
TO TAKE HERSELF SHE'S ABLE TO
NOT TAKE HERSELF TOO SERIOUSLY
AND CAN LAUGH AT HERSELF. WE'VE
HEARD. BUT WE LIVE WITH HER.
TRUTH IS MONIQUE IS ALL OF THIS.
WE KNEW THIS WOULD BE OUR
OPPORTUNITY TO ROAST ARE
ROOMING BUT WE KNOW WE'RE GOING
TO MISS HER IN OUR HOUSE THE
ASSEMBLY HOUSE. I STILL
REMEMBER FLYING IN FOR
ORIENTATION AND MEETING YOU
MONIQUE. LIKE EVERYONE ELSE I
WAS LOOKING FOR A PLACE TO
STAY. I WAS STAYING IN A HOTEL
WELL I LOOKED MONEY COULD
ALREADY OFFERED. SHE'D ALREADY
RENTED A THREE BEDROOM HOUSE. I
WAS LOOKING FOR ONE ROOMMATE.
SHE TOLD SABRINA ABOUT IT AND
THEN LATER TOLD ME BECAUSE
SABRINA HADN'T RESPONDED. THE
SAME DAY SO SABRINA SAID SHE
WANTED TO BE THE ROOMMATE WAS
THE SAME DAY I SAID I WANTED TO
BE ROOMMATES SO THE THREE OF US
MOVED IN TOGETHER. NOT EXACTLY
WHAT MONIQUE WANTED BUT SHE
TOOK A SMALL THIN. AND IT'S
BEEN WONDERFUL I THANK GOD HE
BROUGHT THE THREE OF US
TOGETHER. WE LIVE THE LOOK THE
JOURNEY OF SABRINA'S PREGNANCY.
WE LOVED EVERY MINUTE OF IT.
EXCEPT WHEN SABRINA DIDN'T WANT
TO LIVE WITH US ANYMORE. ONE
SABRINA LEFT US TO HAVE OUR
TRIPLETS. LARA JOINED US WHAT
SMOOTH TRANSITION WE HAVE A
PERFECT SYSTEM. I COOK MONIQUE
AS A SOUS CHEF AND LARA WASHES
DISHES. THE THREE OF US HAVE
BECOME FAST FRIENDS. TO BUT
THROUGH IT ALL WE'VE ALWAYS HAD
ONE CONSTANT AND THAT'S OUR
HONORARY ROOMY LAUDANUM. BUT
KEPT THE HOUSE BALANCED BETWEEN
ALL OF US. DURING HER TENURE IN
THE ASSEMBLY MONIQUE PROVED HER
LEADERSHIP SKILLS AND WAS MOVED
UP QUICKLY SHE AUTHORED
IMPORTANT LEGISLATION
PROTECTING CONSUMERS I WAS EVEN
INVITED TO TESTIFY IN
WASHINGTON DC. MONIQUE IS THE
ASSEMBLY'S LEADER IN AS THE
VICE CHAIR OF THE WOMEN'S
CAUCUS AND AS PART OF THE
EXECUTIVE COMMITTEE IN THE
ELECT CAUCUS. WE'RE GOING TO
MISS MONIQUE. HERE WELL WE ALL
EXCEPT THAT THIS WAS AN
OPPORTUNITY SHE COULDN'T PASS
UP. THE SENATE IS SO VERY LUCKY
TO HAVE MONIQUE IN THEIR HOUSE.
WE'RE JUST GLAD WE STILL GET TO
SHARE OUR LAND PARK HOUSE WITH
HER
MCCARTY YOU ARE RECOGNIZED AND
DISTRIBUTE YES. REALLY GOING TO
SEE A MOVIE YES THANK YOU I'M I
DIDN'T KNOW WE WERE DOING THIS
TODAY BUT I THINK I TOLD YOU
MONTHS AGO ON YOUR LAST DAY
THAT I HAD SOMETHING I WANTED
TO TELL YOU. AND I'M A STUDENT
OF HISTORY AND THE CAPITAL ON
AUG I'LL GET TO THAT STARS YOUR
CONTRIBUTIONS IN A SECOND BUT I
JUST WANT TO KNOW THAT A FEW
OTHER PEOPLE RAISE THEIR MIKE
WE CANALL TALK I THINK BECAUSE
YOU'RE ONE OF THE MOST LIKE
PEOPLE AND ON THE SCREEN
CARPET. AND YOU'RE GOING TO BE
REALLY MATH AND WE KNOW THEY'RE
GOING TO SOLVE ALL OF OUR
PROBLEMS WHEN YOU GO TO THE
SENATE OVER THERE ALL THOSE
ISSUES WE HAVE YOU'RE GOING TO
BE OUR SAVIOR- YOU KNOW YOU.
WERE MY COMMITTEE MEMBER ON SUB
TWO AND A GREAT PARTNER. AND
JUST YOUR PRESENCE YOUR CALL
YOUR ABILITY TO SOLVE PROBLEMS.
AND THINK RATIONALLY. IT'S
SOMETHING THAT I THINK IS- IS
NOT ALWAYS OFTEN. FOR TRADE IN
POLITICS AND STATE GOVERNMENT
AND I'VE NOTICED IT. MIGHT WANT
TO SAY ONE THING ABOUT YOU WHAT
I THOUGHT ABOUT OVER THE YEARS
AND- MY COLLEAGUE FROM PALO
ALTO MENTION IS YOUR BIG BILL
ON PAYDAY LENDING YOUR OF
COURSE THE LEADER- IN A WOMEN'S
**** IS THE VICE CHAIR. BUT YOU
AS A FEMALE LEGISLATOR. YOU
KNOW YOU WALK SOFTLY AND CARRY
A BIG STICK. YOU'RE BARELY OVER
FIVE FOOT TALL BUT SOME OF
THESE BIG BILLS. THAT THE BOYS
COULDN'T GET ACROSS THE FINISH
LINE FOR DECADES. YOU DEBT.
ORGANIZING RIGHTS FOR CHILD
CARE WORKERS TO HAVE A DECENT
PAY. BARGAINING FOR HEALTH CARE
THEIR THEIR OTHER LIVELIHOOD
THE BILL'S AUTHOR MULTIPLE
TIMES YOU GOT ACROSS THE FINISH
LINE FOR TWO DECADES PEOPLE TRY
TO REGULATE THE PAYDAY LENDING
INDUSTRY. COULD MAKE IT HAPPEN
YOU MADE IT HAPPEN SO I THINK
THAT'S PART OF YOUR LEGACY AS
WELL CONGRATULATIONS.
THANK YOU
pFOR YOUR LEADERSHIP ON BEHALF
OF THE WOMEN'S CAUCUS AND THE
BANKING COMMITTEE I APPRECIATE
YOUR WORK BUT AS- MR MCCARTY
SAID WE'LL GET TO WORK WITH YOU
AS YOU HELP US IN THE SENATE.
MISTER CALDERON. IF SOMEONE
WOULD YOU ACCEPT THE
MAGNIFICENT. SO I JUST WANT TO
THANK EVERYONE THIS IT'S A LOT
OF FEELINGS THAT TO I FEEL THIS
HOUSE- AND SO MANY OF YOU HAVE
pI'VE BECOME I DIDN'T COME HERE
AS MONIQUE LIMON FROM SANTA
BARBARA- WITH THE MASTER PLAN
AND I DIDN'T KNOW WHO I WOULD
BE. AS A LEGISLATOR AND SO MANY
OF YOU HAVE INFLUENCE MY
LEGISLATIVE PATH- AND IT WAS A
HARD DECISION AS MANY OF YOU
KNOW BECAUSE WE DISCUSSED THIS
FOR MONTHS ABOUT WHAT I WOULD
DO WHAT I WOULD STAY HERE OR
WHETHER I WOULD GO. AND TO THE-
TO THE SENATE. AT YOU KNOW I
THINK OF MY FRESHMAN CLASS A
FRESH DAMS. IN THE COMING IN
WITH THE EXCITEMENT- OF SERVING
WITH BOTH WE IMMEDIATELY
STARTED. YOU KNOW HOW SOME OF
US AT LEAST THE FANTASY
FOOTBALL LEAGUE THAT. IS JUST-
RECOGNITION ONLY I WILL ADD AND
WE BONDED AND CONSTANTLY DO
OVER FOOTBALL SEASON OVER THAT-
WE CAME IN WITH STRONG IDEAS
WITH ENTHUSIASM TO SERVE THE
PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA. I DO TODD
AND MARK. MAJOR BECAME FRIENDS
IMMEDIATELY- THE END AS BEEN
INCREDIBLY SUPPORTIVE- BOTH
PROFESSIONALLY AND ON THE
PERSONAL SIDE. MY ROOMMATE'S OH
MY GOSH WHO KNEW IT WAS ALL
GOING TO WORK OUT THAT WAY. IN
TERMS OF WHO'S WHO WE'VE BEEN
ROOMMATES WITH- AND IT'S BEEN
INCREDIBLE AND IT YOU KNOW AND
I THINK I'M ALSO JUST SO MANY
MOMENTS THAT I HAD FROM
CARRYING MY VERY FIRST
DIFFICULT BILL AND NOT
UNDERSTANDING WHAT IT DIFFICULT
BILL IS- AND I REMEMBER LORENA
AND ACTUALLY CRISTINA. BEING
LIKE THE FIRST PEOPLE TO SAY
ARE YOU SURE YOU WANT TO DO
THIS DO YOU KNOW WHAT YOU'RE
GETTING YOURSELF INTO YOUR
PREDECESSOR TRIED AND ONLY GOT
TWENTY SOMETHING VOTES. AND I
SAID YEAH I WANT TO DO IT- AND
I REMEMBER THATFIRST TIME THAT
I GOT THE BILL UP- YOU KNOWTO
FOURTEEN I WAS LIKE WHAT THE
HECK I NEED ONE MORE VOTE. AND
I REMEMBER HOW MANY OF YOU WERE
ROOTING ME ON THAT NIGHT AND
WERE SO SUPPORTIVE- AND
IMMEDIATELY ONCE WE GOT THAT
VOTE YOU CAME UP TO ME AND I
WAS LIKE I DID SOMETHING OH MY
GOSH I DID SOMETHING AND I DID
IT BECAUSE I ONLY LOOKED
FORWARD. I WAS IT LOOKING
BACKWARDS AND SO MANY OF YOU
HAVE BEEN INCREDIBLY
SUPPORTIVE- TO ME TO THE PERSON
I'VE BECOME- YOU KNOW THE
SPEAKERS ON THE FLOOR BUT I
KNOW HE'S LISTENING IN HIS TV
BACK THERE- AND I WANT TO THANK
HIM- FOR BEING SUPPORTIVE.
REALLY WELL YOU'RE TO THE
SPEAKER I DON'T THINK THE NEW
THE SPEAKER AND I DID NOT SPEAK
TO EACH OTHER LIKE THE FIRST
YEAR WE DIDN'T KNOW EACH OTHER
THAT WELL- AND SO. IT'S BEEN A
YOU KNOW A JOURNEY- AND ALSO AN
HONOR REALLY TO BE YOU KNOW TO
BE- IN THIS HOUSE UNDER HIS
LEADERSHIP. WITH INCREDIBLE
SUPPORT I AM SURE HE DOUBTED ME
ONCE OR TWICE- BUT I WAS REALLY
COMMITTED TO. MOVING THE ISSUES
FORWARD- IAN. I HAVE A FUNNY
STORY WITH AND I ACTUALLY.
DIDN'T KNOW HOW IAN AND I WERE
GOING TO WORK HELP I WAS LIKE
GOSH IN. IS JUST HARD TO TALK
TO. I'M BUT- BUT IT'S THROUGH
THROUGH THE YEARS THAT YOU KNOW
HE'S BECOMES SOMEONE THAT I'VE
TAKEN DIRECTION FROM AND I'M
LIKE WHAT DO YOU THINK I SHOULD
DO HOW DO YOU THINK I SHOULD DO
IT. AND SO- IT'S YOU KNOW I
JUST APPRECIATE SO MANY OF YOU
IN INFLUENCING THE PERSON I'VE
BECOME. FLOODED IN PERFECT BUT
COMMITTED- I CERTAINLY THINK
THAT THAT'S BEEN SOMETHING- TO
THE WOMEN'S CAUCUS MY GOSH DID
I LEARN A LOT. FROM BEING THE
VICE CHAIR- AND I HOPE TO BE
ABLE TO CONTINUE TO PLAY A ROLE
YOU KNOW WHAT THE CAUCUS BUT
ALL OF YOU. YOUR FEEDBACK YOUR
TEXT YOUR- COMMENTS YOUR
INVOLVEMENT- BOTH YOU KNOW
REPUBLICAN AND DEMOCRATIC
WOMEN. WHO HAVE BEEN THERE TO
SUPPORT ME- THE WOMEN'S CAUCUS
IS SPECIAL VERY SPECIAL. AND WE
HAVE A LOT OF OPINIONS. BUT TO-
EVERY TIME THAT SOMEONE BROUGHT
AN OPINION FORWARD- AND MADE ME
THINK ABOUT WHAT IT'S LIKE TO
BE A LEADER TO BALANCE ALL OF
THIS- IT HELPED ME BECOME A
BETTER PERSON. SO I AM SO
THANKFUL. TO SO MANY PEOPLE TO
ALL THE CHAIRS OF THE
COMMITTEES I'VE SERVED ON ON
HEALTH. ON HOUSING ON MY GOSH.
BEING ON BUDGET SUB TO AND THAT
YOU KNOW AND- THERE'S YOU KNOW
THERE'S- THERE'S A LOT I AM SO
THANKFUL I'M NOT RESOURCES. TO
THE CHAIRS- FOR HAVING ME ALSO
BE INFLUENTIAL- IN THOSE
COMMITTEES AND ALLOWING ME TO
HAVE A VOICE. IN THOSE
COMMITTEE SO YOU KNOW NOTHING
BUT GRATITUDE I'M ONLY GOING
NEXT DOOR. I SAY THAT AND YOU
ALL CONTINUE TO KEEP ME VERY
VERY HUMBLE- ABOUT AND MAKING
SURE I KNOW WHERE I CAME FROM-
AND THAT MY ROOTS ARE HERE IN
THE ASSEMBLY. AND THE ASSEMBLY
IS AT WHO MADE ME THE
LEGISLATOR I AM. SO GRATEFUL I
COULD LITERALLY GO THROUGH
EVERY SINGLE ONE OF YOU AND SAY
SOMETHING THAT CONNECTS ME TO
YOU MY SEAT MATES YOU KNOW. WHO
HAVE BEEN INCREDIBLE MY FELLOW
CO LEGISLATORS WHO ALSO
GOVERNMENT VENTURA AND OJAI
WITH ME I MEAN I COULD SAY
SOMETHING ABOUT. EVERY SINGLE
ONE OF YOU AND EVEN SOME OF YOU
WHO WE NEVER FOUND COMMON
GROUND- BUT I. BUT WE ALWAYS
TRIED- SO THANK YOU
UNBELIEVABLE GRATITUDE. I
REALLY AM GOING TO MISS. BEING
ON THE GREEN CARPET AS MUCH AS
I AM MORE. THAN YOU ALL KNOW
THAT THANK YOU. MISTER CALDERON
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED YEAH AND I
JUST WANT TO. ALLOW MEMBERS AN
OPPORTUNITY CAN UNDERSTAND HOW
WE'RE DOING THESE TRIBUTES-
WE'RE WE'RE LIMITING EVERY
TRIBUTE TO THREE MEMBERS AND
THAT'S NOT THAT'S NOT TO BE
MEAN- THAT'S JUST RECOGNIZING
THAT WE'RE GONNA BE IN A
POSITION. ON MONDAY WE'RE GONNA
HAVE A COUPLE TRIBUTE TO GO
THROUGH AND WE'RE GOING TO VERY
FAST APPROACH BEEN NINE IS
GONNA BE A LOT OF WORK TO GET
DONE. SO WE JUST ASK THAT
EVERYBODY RESPECTS THAT IT'S
THREE SPEAKERS PER MEMBER
THAT'S LEAVING FOR A TRIBUTE. I
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MISTER
CALDERON. MOVING TO INTERVIEW
FOR MR OBERNOLTE. DR WEBER YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED. THE MESSAGE
WHAT IS THE PRICE OF MR SPEAKER
AND MEMBERS I AM I AM REALLY
REALLY HONORED THAT JAY ASKED
ME TO SAY SOMETHING CONCERNING
HIM ON THIS HOUSE AND HIM
LEAVING AND- SOMEONE JUST
COMMENTED WOW THAT'S A SURPRISE
TO TWO PEOPLE WHO YOU THINK ARE
VERY DIFFERENT. AND YET ONE OF
THINGS I DISCOVERED IS THAT
WE'RE NOT WE'RE VERY MUCH ALIKE.
YOU KNOW IT REMINDS ME
SOMETIMES WHEN I GET PRESENTS
THAT ARE COME TO ME AND THEY'RE
BEAUTIFULLY WRAPPED. YOU KNOW
AND THEY HAVE ALL ONE OF THE
BUTTONS IN THE BOWLS AND THE
EAGLES IN THE TRIANGLES AND
STUFF YOU ALMOST HATE AND RAPID
BECAUSE IT'S SO PRETTY. BUT
OFTEN TIMES THAT I GET A LOT OF
YES FROM. FROM FRIENDS AND-
FAMILY AND SOMETIMES WHEN I
OPEN IT IT'S REALLY. VERY
PRETTY STUFF BUT AT NOT VERY
USEFUL. SO I HAVE DRAWERS AND
DRAWERS OF CANDLES AND SCENTED
STUFF AND YOU KNOW LEFT TO PUT
THINGS MOST OF YOU HAVE A LOT
OF THAT. HAVE A LOT OF THAT
STUFF AND COULD NOT ONLY
BECOMING BEAUTIFUL PACKAGES. SO
IT'S ALWAYS INTERESTING TO ME
WHEN I GET A PACKAGE. AND IT SO
BEAUTIFULLY WRAPPED BUT IT IS
CITED AS SOME REALLY PRACTICAL
STUFF. AND I THINK ABOUT WHEN I
YOU KNOW TO JUST SO YOU GET
THIS BEAUTIFUL PACKAGE. AND IT
IS SOME SCREWDRIVERS AND SOME
HAMMERS INSTANCE GROUPS SINCE
THE THINGS THAT YOU REALLY NEED
THAT ARE USEFUL SEPTATE. ALL
THOSE THINGS YOU THINK WOW.
THIS IS A NICELY WRAPPED
PACKAGE WITH SUCH ORDINARY
STUFF. YOU KNOW AND BUDGET IT
BECOMES A PATH STUFF THAT YOU
USE MUCH MORE THAN ANYTHING
ELSE. AND I THINK ABOUT WHEN I
FIRST HEARD THE JAY OBERNOLTE
WAS COMING. I THOUGHT WHAT A
WEIRD NAME. THIS FOUR K. LIVE
HIS WHOLE WITH OLD. YOU KNOW. I
MEAN. IS SO. IT SO'S GOT OF
INTERESTING WHEN THEY TOLD HE
WAS COME. THEN I TOLD ME HE'S
REALLY RICH THAT'S THE FIRST
THING I TOLD HIM ABOUT HIS
REALLY RICH. AND HE FLIES HIS
OWN PLANE. AND SOMEONE TOLD ME
NOT JUST A- LITTLE PLANE THAT
JUST PUT PUT PUT BUT IT
ABSOLUTELY GORGEOUS PLANE. THAT
HE FLIES INTO TO THE CAPITOL
EVERY BISHOP EVERY WEEK. AND
THAT HE LIVES IN A PENTHOUSE. I
THOUGHT OH MY GOD YOU KNOW THIS
IS A GAME OF THIS BEAUTIFULLY
WRAPPED PERSON. AND I THOUGHT
OH MY GOODNESS HOW RELEVANT
HE'S GONNA BE. AND HOW IT-
AGAIN HE'S GOING TO BE. AND HOW
HE'S GOING TO MAKE US ALL FEEL%
SO SMALL BECAUSE WE DON'T HAVE
ALL THE GOOD STUFF HE HAS. AND
HOW WILL I EVER EXPLAIN TO HIM.
WHAT LIFE IS LIKE IN THE
SEVENTY NINTH ASSEMBLY DISTRICT.
HOWEVER EXPLAINED TO HIM MY
LIFE. AND THOSE THINGS THAT ARE
IMPORTANT TO ME. THE DRIVE THE
EVERYDAY PERSON IN CALIFORNIA.
BUT I SAID I WON'T I'LL GIVEN
THE BENEFIT OF THE DOUBT. AND
I'LL SEE WHAT IT'S REALLY LIKE.
AND THEN WE HAD OUR BOWLING
EXPERIENCE AND HE PROBABLY
DOESN'T EVEN REMEMBER THIS
BECAUSE MY OFFICE WAS KIND OF
NEXT TO HIS. AND HE CAN REALLY
BOWL. AND I SAID NO RICH DO
GLOBAL LIKE THIS. YOU KNOW HOW
HE WOULD HAVE HIS BUTLER'S
BOWLING HE DIDN'T TAKE THE
SCORE I MEAN YOU KNOW THERE'S
NO THERE'S NO WAY THAT HE COULD
HAVE THIS LEVEL OF BALI AND HE
WAS STRIKING THINGS AND HE WAS
JUST I MEAN IT REALLY WAS
REMINDED ME OF THE DAYS WHEN I
WAS A KID AND WE ACTUALLY HAD
THESE. FOLKS WHO COULD REALLY
BOWL YOU KNOW BECAUSE THIS
GENERATION DOESN'T REALLY BALL
A LOT BUT NINETY IT NOTHING
COULD PRETTY CAN GET HOLD THIS
BALDING FROM AND THEN I HAD A
CHANCE TO SEE HIS WIFE AND SHE
WASN'T YOU KNOW. ALL THAT SHE
WAS LIKE YOU KNOW SOMETHING
FROM ANOTHER COUNTRY SHE WAS
JUST AN ORDINARY EVERYDAY
WOMAN. AND I THOUGHT HOME THIS
IS A DIFFERENT PERSON THIS IS A
DIFFERENT PACKAGE THIS IS
CONTENT THAN THE PACKAGE I GOT
THAT WAS ALL WRAPPED PRETTY.
AND I DECIDED I WOULD
INVESTIGATE WHO THIS PERSON IS.
AND I BEGAN TO TALK TO HIM. AND
I LEARNED IS JUST HOW MUCH HE
WAS LIKE ME. A KID WHO GREW UP
WITH VERY LITTLE. BUT WHOSE
PARENTS BELIEVED STRONGLY IN
HIM HIS MOTHER. RAISED IN WITH
SOME VERY STRONG VALUES ABOUT
LIFE AND PEOPLE AND HIS FAMILY.
AND HOW MUCH SHE CARED ABOUT
CALIFORNIA. AND HOW MUCH YOU
CAN REACH ACROSS THE LINES IN
THE IN THE PARTY'S AND
BASICALLY GET TO THE ISSUES
THAT WOULD BE HERE. I LEARNED
HE WAS VERY SMART. AND ONE OF
THINGS I'VE ALWAYS TRIED TO MY
LIFE BECAUSE PEOPLE LOOK AT YOU
AND SAY ALL YOU HAVE ALL THESE
DEGREES I'VE TRIED TO MAKE SURE
PEOPLE UNDERSTOOD THAT THOSE
DEGREES DIDN'T DEFINE ME. THERE
WERE THINGS I DID IN ORDER TO
MAKE MY LIFE A LITTLE EASIER
BUT I WAS STILL THIS LITTLE
GIRL FROM PROJECTS. AND WHEN I
MET HIM HE WAS STILL THIS
ORDINARY PERSON. HE WAS SMART
BUT IT WAS AN ARROGANT. AND I
COULD SIT AND TALK TO HIM ABOUT
EDUCATIONAL ISSUES AND HIS
FAMILY AND HIS CHILDREN AND HOW
HE WAS RAISING HIS SONS. AND
UNDERSTAND THE CONFLICTS THAT
HE WAS IN WITH REGARDS TO ONE
BEING ONE WAY AND ONE BEING
ANOTHER THE KIND OF CHALLENGES
THAT FAMILIES HAVE. ANY REALLY
WAS CONCERNED ABOUT THEM. I
LEARNED A LOT ABOUT HIS WIFE
AND HOW MUCH SHE CARED ABOUT
HIM AND THE FAMILY. AND HOW HE
EVERYTHING HE DID WAS REALLY
DESIGNED TO BUILD A STRONG
FAMILY. BUT I LEARNED A OF HIM
ONE TIME WHEN I WAS MY FAMILY
WAS DEBATING WHERE WE'RE GOING
TO GO FOR. THE NEW YEAR FOR
THANKSGIVING. AND WE HAD A
CHOICE BETWEEN JAMAICA.A
HAWAII IN BIG BEAR. I WANT TO
GO TO BIG BEAR OKAY EVERYBODY
ELSE WILL SOMEWHERE ELSE. AND
SO I WENT TO JANE I SAID J. CAN
YOU GIVE ME SOME
RECOMMENDATIONS. OF SOME NICE
PLACES IN BIG BEAR WHAT WE
COULD STAY WE'LL GET A NICE
PLACE TO STAY. SO I SAID SURE I
CAN DO THAT. OKAY THANK YOU. SO
WHAT I'M GONNA WEAR THAT
THURSDAY CAME BACK OF MONDAY HE
SAID. YOU DON'T HAVE A LIST FOR
YOU HE SAYS BUT- WE HAVE
ANOTHER RECOMMENDATION I SAID
OKAY WHAT IS THAT. HE SAID.
WE'RE GOING TO GO AWAY FOR
THANKSGIVING AND YOU CAN HAVE A
HOUSE. I SAID WHAT. HE SAID YOU
AND YOUR FAMILY CAN STAY AT
HOME. AND I THOUGHT THIS IS
REALLY WE NEVER HAD SOMEBODY
WHO KIND OF KNOWS ME THAT WE'VE
TALKED A LOT ABOUT WHO TRUST ME
WITH HIS HOUSE. BUT IT ALSO
SAID A LOT ABOUT THE FACT THAT
POSSESSIONS WERE NOT REALLY
THAT IMPORTANT. IT'S NICE TO
HAVE BUT IT'S MORE IMPORTANT TO
SHARE. AND HE REALLY WAS HONEST
ABOUT IT. OF COURSE MY FAMILY
CHOSE GO TO Y. COURSE. BUT I
FELT SO HONORED I FELT SO
HONORED THAT DESPITE THAT YOU
KNOW I TOLD WE WOULD WANT TO
WHY BUT I TOLD MY FAMILY I SAID
YOU KNOW I FEEL VERY
COMFORTABLE THAT IF WE WANTED
TO GO TO BIG BEAR. THAT WE
WOULD NOT BE IMPOSING UPON HIM.
AND THAT WAS JUST A SMALL
EXAMPLE WHEN I'M STRUGGLING
WITH THE ISSUE OF COMING BACK
AND WHETHER NOT OF MY AGE IT
WOULD BE SMART. WHAT WE WOULD
DO THOSE KINDS OF THINGS AND
WAS COMMITTEE HEARING IT. WE
GOT INFORMATION THAT WE COULD
REMOTE AND WE COULDN'T MOVE
BACK AND FORTH BACK AND FORTH.
AND I SAID WELL IT WAS RIGHT
AFTER THE ALL THE PANDEMIC
STARTED. AND OFFERED TO PICK ME
UP. IN THIS PLANE J. AND I SAID
NO I CAN'T HAVE YOU FLY BACK IN
GO FORWARD YOU CAN YOU KNOW TO
COME GET ME AND I BUT I BUT I
KNEW THAT IF I WANTED IT. HE
WOULD DO IT. AND HE WOULD DO I
WOULD LOVE AND GRATEFULNESS AND
WE'RE CALLING THIS. WE HAVE
BEEN TRULY BLESSED TODAY BY YOU
BEING HERE. BECAUSE YOU STAND
OUT IN A VERY UNIQUE WAY.
YOU'RE SMART BUT YOU'RE NOT
ERICA. YOU'RE KIND AND GENTLE
AND WHEN YOU MAKE POINTS ABOUT
THINGS WE NEED TO DO WE DON'T
FEEL ATTACKED AND OFFENDED. WE
FEEL ENLIGHTENED BY YOUR
PERSPECTIVE PERSPECTIVE AND WE
FEEL THAT YOUR HELPFUL. VERY
HELPFUL IN THE ISSUES THAT WE
REYES BUT YOU GIVE US A
PERSPECTIVE IT'S NOT
NECESSARILY GROUNDED JUSTIN
PARTY BUT GROUNDED IN FACTS AND
INFORMATION AND YOU CHALLENGES
EVERYDAY TO BE BETTER. WHEN I
HEARD YOU WERE GOING TO RUN
FOR. CONGRESS I WAS REALLY SAD.
I WAS REALLY SAD BUT IT I KNOW
I SAID WELL MAYBE JUST MAYBE
THIS IS WHAT CONGRESS NEEDS
WHICH IS A TREMENDOUS CHALLENGE
TO TAKE SOMEBODY LIKE YOU AND
PUTIN THE MIDST OF. ALL THE
STUFF THAT'S HAPPENING WHEN YOU
REALLY ARE PERSON WHO WANTS THE
OF THE FINAL. PRODUCT TO MAKE
SURE THAT THINGS ARE BETTER.
BUT I WISH YOU WELL. YOU'LL
ALWAYS BE MY FRIEND. UNION WIFE
WILL ALWAYS BE WELCOME IN SAN
DIEGO TO MY HOME. AND I HOPE AT
SOME POINT. I WILL GET A CHANCE
TO EXPRESS THAT TO YOU AND YOUR
FAMILY WHEN WE CAN BE. CLOSER
TOGETHER. AND BETTER. MORE
FRIENDLY. WE WILL COME TO BIG
BEAR SOON. I HOPE. IN THE NEAR
FUTURE. AND I WILL FEEL EVEN
BETTER THAN I DID WHEN I WAS A
KID AND USED TO GO TO BIG BEER
BECAUSE- I DON'T HAVE TO GO TO
A CAMP ACTING THE VISIT JAY
OBERNOLTE AND HIS FAMILY. AND
KNOW THAT I WILL BE WELCOME.
AND I WISH YOU AND YOUR WIFE
YOUR FAMILY THE BEST. AND IF
CONGRESS DOESN'T WORK OUT YOU
STILL HAVE A WHOLE. THANK YOU.
THANK. THANK YOU DR WEBER MR
LOW YOU ARE RECOGNIZED. K. TRY
TO MAKE THIS A VERY SHORT AND
SWEET. HEY SCIRI. WHAT IS THE
TEXTBOOK DEFINITION OF
STATEMENT. WHAT WOULD YOU LIKE
TO KNOW ABOUT JAY OBERNOLTE.
FOR THOSE OF YOU WHO KNOW- JAY
IS A TECHIE. A GAMER. GAMERS
AND GAMING. I SAID YOU KNOW THE
ENEMY. SORRY HEATHER WHEREVER
YOU'RE AT. AND HE KNOWS HIS
STUFF. I CAME INTO THIS
LEGISLATIVE BODY AND FRESHMAN
ORIENTATION WITH JAY OBERNOLTE
AND YOU KNOW WE HAVE TO SORT OF
STAY IN OUR SILOS ABOUT
DEMOCRATS AND REPUBLICANS
STAYING IN THEIR OWN CORNERS
BUT WE CONNECTED AND I WAS VERY
INTRIGUED TO WHICH HE SAID I'M
A GAMER AND I KNOW THESE
THINGS. AND IN FACT WE'VE BEEN
TO GAMERS CONFERENCES VIDEO
GAME CONFERENCES IN CALIFORNIA
THERE IS A TIME TO WHICH HE
SAID HEY DO YOU WANT TO JOIN ME
ON MY PLANE. AND I'M AFRAID OF
FLYING. AND J. AS A PILOT. IN A
SMALL PLANE. AND I AS TOOK PART
OF TO MYSELF NO I DON'T WANT TO
GO BECAUSE I WAS TOO SCARED
I'LL JUST GO ON SOUTHWEST BUT
THEY SAID. BUT IT'S J. SO I. I
LITERALLY HAVE TRUSTED. YOU J.
WITH MY LIFE. AND HERE WE FLEW.
UPON TAKING OFF THERE WAS
SIGNIFICANT TURBULENCE. OKAY
WITHHOLDING UNDER THE SEATS AND
SAID WELL WHATEVER YOU WANT LOW
AYE PLEASE DON'T KILL IT. OF
WE'RE I'M STILL HERE HERE WITH
EVERY WEEK HE FLEW PERFECTLY
BUT I SURE THIS THESE
EXPERIENCES BECAUSE YOU KNOW WE
HAVE TO HAVE SOME. GOOD FUN
WITH EACH OTHER AND SOME GREAT
CAMARADERIE. AND I FEEL THAT.
IMMENSELY I NOT ONLY IF YOU'VE
HAD THE BENEFIT OF BEING AT HIS
BIPARTISAN DINNERS AND WHICH IS
NOT ONLY GOOD FOOD BUT GOOD
CONVERSATIONS ONE THAT I WANTED
TO GO TO ONE THAT I LOOK
FORWARD TO GOING TO AND I KNOW
MANY OF YOU HAVE ALSO JOINED
AND HOPE SOMEONE WILL TAKE THE
MANTLE. FROM ASSEMBLYMAN
OBERNOLTE TO ENSURE THAT WE ARE
BREAKING BREAD. AND TALKING TO
EACH OTHER NOT AROUND EACH
OTHER NOT THROUGH EACH OTHER.
BUT WITH EACH OTHER. SIMILARLY
J. HAS SERVED ON THE BUSINESS
OF PROFESSIONS COMMITTEE FOR A
NUMBER OF YEARS NOW AND THIS
SOME OF YOU KNOW IT'S VERY.
WONKY IN INTO THE WEEDS AND SO
AS I HAD TRIED TO BRIEF A
NUMBER OF COLLEAGUES AND
MEMBERS USUALLY WHICH IS BEEN
FIVE MINUTES BUT I KNEW THAT
WHEN I WAS ABOUT TO CALL JAY
OBERNOLTE MIGHT HAVE TAKEN A
LITTLE LONGER BECAUSE HE KNEW
EXACTLY WHAT WE WERE TALKING
ABOUT AND IT WAS THAT MUCH MORE
PREPARE. AREA COME WITHOUT
NOTES AND SPEAKING SPECIFICALLY
TO THESE ISSUES AND
RESPECTFULLY WHEN DISAGREEING
DO SO WITH DEEP RESPECT. AND
ADMIRATION FOR THE PRESENTER
FOR THE AUTHOR FOR THIS
INSTITUTION. I KNOW THAT WE
WILL ALL BE WELL SERVED IF WE
CAN CONTINUE. TO EMBODY THE
SAME TYPE OF PRINCIPLES OF
BEING MAGNANIMOUS MAINTAINING A
LEVEL OF INTEGRITY. DOING THE
HARD WORK. AND REPRESENTING OUR
COMMUNITY THAT MUCH BETTER. SO
AGAIN TO J. ANYTIME WE LOOK
FORWARD TO CONTINUING TO HAVE
AN OPEN DOOR. I WITH YOU
SERVING IN CONGRESS WILL MISS
YOU DEARLY. BUT KNOW THAT YOU
HAVE HAD LASTING EFFECTS HERE
NOT ONLY TO ME BUT TO MANY
OTHERS WILL FOLLOW IN YOUR
FOOTSTEPS WE WILL MISS YOU WE
WISH YOU ALL THE BEST AND WE
LOVE YOU. THANK YOU MR ROSE
EUREX. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
AND MEMBERS- I JUST FOUND OUT
THAT WE WERE DOING A TRIBUTE TO
J. TODAY AND- REALLY WANTED TO
MAKE SURE THAT I WAS ABLE TO
PUT SOME OF MY MEMORIES OUT
THERE- MY FIRST RECOGNITION OF
WORKING WITH JAY. WAS WHEN I
WAS FLOOR LEADER SO I WAS ARE
IT WAS A NEW FLOOR LEADER AND I
WANTED TO MAKE SURE EVERYBODY
KNEW WHAT WAS GOING ON AND J.
WAS SITTING OVER THERE I THINK
CLOSE TO WHERE FRANK IS SITTING
NOW. AND I REMEMBER WE HAD A
WHOLE SLEW OF BILLS ADDED TO
THE FILE I MEAN THE MUST HAVE
BEEN FIFTEEN OR EIGHTEEN BILLS
ADDED AND I WENT UP WITH THE
LIST AND I STARTED TELLING HIM
THE FILE NUMBER IN THE BILL
NUMBER AND HE JUST KEPT LOOKING
AT ME. AND I'M LIKE IS HE GOING
TO WRITE THESE DOWN AND WHY
WENT THROUGH THEM ONE AT THE
TIME AND HE SAID OKAY I GOT IT
AND I'M LIKE THAT'S JAY
OBERNOLTE HE HAS A BRAIN I
ALWAYS SAID LIKE A COMPUTER
JUST TAKES IN THE INFORMATION
CAN PROCESS IT IN AN ORDERLY
MANNER AND COME OUT WITH AN
AMAZING RESULTS AND I WAS I WAS
BLOWN AWAY BY THAT SO. THAT'S
THE FIRST TIME I HAD WORKED
WITH HIM- WHEN I WAS FLOOR
LEADER I'M THE WORK IS DONE AS
BUDGET CHAIR I MEAN WEEK WE ALL
KNOW HOW AMAZING HE'S BEEN.
PEAKING WITHOUT NOTES KNOWING.
ABOUT THE BUDGET IN. AND OUT
WORKING. WITHTHE BUDGET CHAIR-
YOU KNOW IT'S BEEN FANTASTIC
WE'RE- AND- YOU KNOW IS THIS
THE- BEEN SUCH AN ASSET TO OUR
HOUSE. AS WE WORK ON THAT VERY
IMPORTANT. ISSUE HERE IN THE
ASSEMBLY- WHEN I BECAME LEADER.
I APPOINTED JAY TO BE OUR
CAUCUS CHAIR. HE HAS BEEN
THERE. PRETTY MUCH ALL THE TIME
I THINK HE'S ONLY MISSED ONE
MEETING. ALWAYS ALWAYS READY
ALWAYS PREPARED. RUNNING OUR
OUR CAUCUS AND I'VE APPRECIATED
THAT VERY MUCH YOU KNOW IT
ABOUT SOME OF THE PERSONAL
THINGS HE'S VERY BALANCED IN
HIS LIFE HE THOSE THOSE
TRIATHLONS AND ALL KINDS OF
DIFFERENT TYPES OF EVENTS LIKE
THAT. YOU KNOW THAT KEEPS YOU
KIND OF A MORE OF A BALANCE-
WHEN I MY FAMILY WENT UP TO
LAKE ARROWHEAD. I CALLED JAY
AND HEATHER AND I SAID ALL WERE
UP HERE AND- THEY CAME OVER ALL
THE WAY I KNOW THAT WE'RE GOING
THE NEEDLES I THINK THAT. THAT
WEEKEND WHICH IS DISTRICT IS
HUGE SO HE HAD ACTUALLY THAT-
OBLIGATION TO DO CAME DOWN TO
LAKE ARROWHEAD TO VISIT US IN
THE IT'S YOU KNOW SINCE LIKE
ARROWHEADS VERY CLOSE TO BIG
BEAR IT'S IN THE SAME THIS. AND
OUR THAT- YOU KNOW THAT HE TOOK
THE TIME TO DO THAT- ALSO AS
WAS MENTIONED THE BIPARTISAN
DINNERS. THE TACO NIGHTS
HEATHER MAKING THESE TACOS
JUST. BAR NONE AMAZING AND ALL
THE TIMES WE WERE ABLE TO SPEND
OVER AT THEIR PLACE- ENJOYING
TIME TOGETHER AND CAMARADERIE.
REALLY BROUGHT US ALL TOGETHER
SO YOU KNOW YOU'LL BE A GREAT
ASSET TO CONGRESS NO DOUBT
ABOUT IT. BUT A BIG LOSS FOR US
HERE IN THIS HOUSE AND I KNOW
WE'LL KEEP IN TOUCH BUT I WANT
TO THANK YOU FOR EVERYTHING
YOU'VE DONE. IT'S JUST AMAZING
MEMBER AND THE GREAT INTEGRITY
AND ABILITY SO- WE WISH YOU
LUCK THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
OBERNOLTE THE FLOOR IS YOURS
THANK YOU EVERYONE FOR THE KIND
WORDS AND THE NOT SO KIND WORDS
I WANT YOU ALL TO KNOW THAT-
SERVING AS A MEMBER OF THIS
BODY AND SERVING WITH ALL OF
YOU IS MY COLLEAGUES HAS BEEN
ONE OF THE HIGH HONORS OF MY
LIFE. WHEN I WAS FIRST ELECTED.
TO THE ASSEMBLY SIX YEARS AGO.
I TOOK SOME TIME AND MET WITH.
DEPARTING MEMBERS OF THE
LEGISLATURE BECAUSE I WANTED TO
SEE WHAT ADVICE THEY WOULD GIVE
TO A NEOPHYTE FRESHMAN. AND
MUCH TO MY SURPRISE. MOST OF
THEM SAID THIS THEY SAID THE
THING THAT I'M GOING TO MISS
THE MOST. IS THE RELATIONSHIPS
THAT I BUILT. WITH THE PEOPLE
THAT I SERVE WITH. AND THAT
REALLY WENT COUNTER TO MY
EXPECTATIONS COMING INTO THE
BODY I THOUGHT IT WAS VERY
PARTISAN I THOUGHT IT WAS ERY
POLITICAL I REALLY HADN'T
GRASPED THIS IDEA. THAT YOU
COULD BUILD PERSONAL
FRIENDSHIPS AND RELATIONSHIPS.
WITH SEVENTY NINE OTHER PEOPLE
AND FORTY PEOPLE IN THE SENATE.
BUT NOW AS I LOOK BACK ON MY
TIME I THINK THEY WERE
ABSOLUTELY RIGHT BECAUSE THAT'S
THE THING THAT I AM GOING TO
CHURCH THE MOST. IS MY
FRIENDSHIPS AND MY
RELATIONSHIPS WITH SOME AMAZING
PEOPLE THAT I SERVE WITH. WHAT
WHAT I WAS FIRST ELECTED. I
REMEMBER FRESHMAN ORIENTATION
WAS RUN BY RICH GORDON RIMMER
RICH. AN AMAZING HUMAN BEING AN
AMAZING FRIEND. AND. I REMEMBER
THAT BEING ONE OF THE
HIGHLIGHTS OF MY FIRST TERM AND
SO WHEN HE TURNED OUT I SAID TO
HIM RICH. THESE BIPARTISAN
DINNERS YOU KNOW REALLY CHANGED
MY TRAJECTORY OF THE
LEGISLATURE IN- WE NEED TO KEEP
DOING THEM SO LET ME KNOW WHO
YOU ARE PICKING BECAUSE I WANT
TO HELP. AND HE SAID WHAT J. NO
ONE HAS STEPPED UP SO IT'S
GOING TO BE YOU. AND I SAID
RICH I DON'T KNOW IF YOU'VE
NOTICED BUT I'M A REPUBLICAN.
ANY SORT OF DOESN'T MATTER
THEY'RE BIPARTISAN DINNERS AND
SO FOR THE LAST FEW YEARS
HEATHER AND I HAVE BEEN DOING
THOSE AND- WHAT A BLESSING IT'S
BEEN FOR US TO ACTUALLY SIT
DOWN BREAK BREAD WITH PEOPLE.
GET TO KNOW. COLLEAGUES ON A
PERSONAL LEVEL KIND OF OUTSIDE
OF THE BUILDING IN THE HUSTLE
AND BUSTLE OF LEGISLATION- IT'S
BEEN AMAZING AND SO I WANT TO
CHALLENGE YOU SOMEBODY'S GONNA
TAKE UP THAT MANTLE BECAUSE
IT'S AN IMPORTANT PROGRAM. IT'S
AN IMPORTANT EFFORT AND
SOMEBODY NEEDS TO STEP UP AND
DO IT SO. LET ME KNOW IF I CAN
HELP. ANOTHER THING THAT HAS
BEEN. REALLY UNEXPECTED AND
AMAZING TO ME IS THAT SOME OF
THE PEOPLE. THAT I BUILT THE
CLOSEST FRIENDSHIPS AND
RELATIONSHIPS WITH ON THIS
FLOOR HAVE BEEN THE PEOPLE. I
ACTUALLY FROM A POLICY
STANDPOINT DISAGREE WITH THE
MOST. AND AT FIRST IT SEEMED
VERY ODD TO ME BUT IN
RETROSPECT I THINK IT'S VERY
NATURAL BECAUSE I THINK WE HAVE
AN OBLIGATION. NOT ONLY IS
LAWMAKERS BUT AS HUMAN BEINGS
TO BROADEN OUR HORIZONS. TO
SEEK OUT ALTERNATE OPINIONS AT
THE FIGURE OUT WHAT IT IS IN
SOMEONE'S BACKGROUND THAT MAKES
THEM HOLD. A VIEWPOINT THAT'S
SO DIFFERENT FROM THE ONE THAT
WE HOLD. BECAUSE ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT- THAT I TREASURE
ABOUT THE FRIENDSHIPS I'VE
BUILT HERE. IS THAT THERE'S
ALWAYS A REASON. I MEAN WE ARE
HERE. FOR THE SAME PURPOSE
WE'RE ALL ON THE SAME TEAM WE
PLAY FOR TEAM CALIFORNIA. AND
WE ALL CARE PASSIONATELY ABOUT
MAKING LIFE BETTER FOR THE
PEOPLE THAT ELECTED US THE
PEOPLE WE REPRESENT. SO IF WE
DISAGREE ON SOMETHING IT'S GOT
TO BE SOMETHING FUNDAMENTAL
ABOUT UR BACKGROUND. AND WE
ALL BRING. DIFFERENT
EXPERIENCES AND DIFFERENT A
DIFFERENT LIFE EXPERIENCE TO
OUR SERVICE HERE. SO I'VE BEEN
FASCINATED TO TALK TO PEOPLE
ABOUT WHAT IT IS YOU KNOW I
THINK THIS YOU THINK THAT OKAY
I WANT TO KNOW WHY. YOU HOLD
THAT VIEWPOINT SO PASSIONATELY.
SO I WANT TO THANK YOU. ALL OF
YOU FOR GIVING ME THAT
EDUCATION. AND FOR GIVING THE
OPPORTUNITY TO GET TO KNOW YOU-
IT IS REALLY REALLY BAD ON ONE
OF THE HIGHLIGHTS OF MY LIFE.
AND I- SO BIG THANK YOUS FIRST
OF ALL TO MY STAFF. WE ALL KNOW
THAT WE COULDN'T DO WHAT WE DO
HERE IN THE LEGISLATURE WITHOUT
THE HELP OF OUR STAFF I'VE HAD
AN AMAZING STAFF. BOTH HERE IN
THE CAPITAL AND IN THE
DISTRICT. I'VE BEEN BLESSED TO
HAVE VERY LITTLE STAFF TURNOVER
SO IT'S BEEN KIND OF A CONSTANT
PRESENCE IN MY LIFE. AND SO I
WANT TO SAY THANK YOU FOR THE
PEOPLE. THAT I'VE HAD THE
PLEASURE TO WORK WITH I'M TOLD.
THAT I'M NOT THE EASIEST PERSON
TO WORK FOR. I DON'T THINK THAT
THAT'S TRUE FOR THE RECORD BUT-
WITH I VERY MUCH APPRECIATE THE-
THAT THEY'VE GIVEN ME SIX YEARS
OF THEIR LIFE. I ALSO WANT TO
SAY A BIG. THANK YOU TO MY
FAMILY AND MY WIFE HEATHER. HAS
BEEN. SHE'S BEEN JUST AMAZING
WHEN THE BIG THE BIG FEARS THAT
I HAD WHEN I WAS ELECTED IS
THAT I DIDN'T WANT TO GO TO
SACRAMENTO AND HAVE A LIFE
APART FROM HER. AND SO WE KIND
OF MADE A DEAL WHEN I GOT
THROUGH THE PRIMARY THAT THAT
SHE WOULD COME ONE WEEK A
MONTH. UP TO SACRAMENTO WITH
ME. BECAUSE IF I SAID. YOU KNOW
THAT- ASSEMBLY MEN TAKEN I HAD.
A LUNCH OF PIZZA ROCK WHEN
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT MY DAY I
WANT I WANT. TO KNOW WHO
FILLERS ANO FOR TO KNOW WHERE
PETE'S ARRAKIS. ADDED WANTED TO
HAVE THAT LIFE APART FROM HER.
AND SO SHE CAME UP HERE STARTED
COMING UP ONE WEEK A MONTH AND
HERE'S THE THING I REALLY
DIDN'T FACTOR AND- EVERYONE
LIKES HER BETTER THAN ME. SO
BUT IT'S BEEN AMAZING TO HAVE
HER WE WELCOMED UP HERE AND- TO
SHARE THIS EXPERIENCE WITH HER
AND I WANT TO SAY THE ALSO
THANK YOU TO MY CHILDREN. MOST
OF YOUR PARENTS AND HERE YOU
KNOW WHAT A SACRIFICE IT IS FOR
OUR FAMILIES FOR US TO BE HERE.
FOUR DAYS A WEEK. EVERY SINGLE
WEEK- I MISSED A LOT OF PARITY
TO CONFERENCES MISSED A LOT OF
SCHOOL EVENTS. MISSED A LOT OF
PLAYS- MISSED A LOT OF SPORTING
EVENTS. AND SO I AM VERY
TARGETED THE FACT THAT. THEY
ARE THE ONES THAT PAY THAT PART
OF THE PRICE FOR MY PUBLIC
SERVICE. AND ALSO WANT TO THANK
A- I THANK RE THANK OUR
LEADERSHIP BUT IT'S BEEN
AMAZING TO BE IN CAUCUS
LEADERSHIP FOR THE SIX YEARS
THAT I'VE SERVEDHERE. AND I
THINK IT OF OUR SPEAKER. A
REALLY. CREATES A VERY
BIPARTISAN ATMOSPHERE MAKES ALL
OF US FEEL WELCOME. BOB AND IN
CLOSING I WANT TO SAY. THAT
THERE'S ONE MORE THING I'M
THANKFUL FOR THE FIRST DAY THAT
I WALK ON TO THIS FLOOR I WAS
OVERCOME BY A SENSE OF AWE.
WHEN I WALKED INTO THE CHAMBER
IS THE FACT THAT WE GET TO
SERVE. THE NEEDS OF FORTY
MILLION CALIFORNIANS THAT
THEY'RE ENTRUSTING US TO MAKE
GOOD DECISIONS FOR THEM HERE I
JUST I MEAN IT WAS I WAS
UNBELIEVABLE BUT I WAS
ACTUALLY. BEING ENTRUSTED TO
PUSH THOSE BUTTONS. AND I
THOUGHT TO MYSELF THE ON THAT
DAY SIX YEARS AGO. I HOPE I
NEVER LOSE THE SENSE OF AWE.
WHEN I WALK IN THIS CHAMBER
BECAUSE IF I EVER CAN WALK INTO
THE CHAMBER AND THINK WELL YOU
KNOW WHAT THIS IS MY ORDINARY
LIFE- IT AND- I DIDN'T TAKE FOR
GRANTED THE RESPONSIBILITY I
HAVE WELL IT'S TIME TO MOVE ON.
AND DO SOMETHING ELSE IN LIFE
AND I'M PROUD TO SAY THAT THAT
EVERY DAY SINCE THEN I'VE
WALKED THROUGH THOSE DOORS.
WITH A SENSE OF AWE AND WONDER.
SO I WANT TO THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR BEING MY FRIENDS MY
COMPANIONS ON THIS JOURNEY-
AND- AS YES MY COLLEAGUES TOLD
ME SIX YEARS AGO. THE WIDELY
WITH THE SENSE THAT THE THING
THAT I'M GONNA MISS THE MOST IS
ALL OF YOUR FRIENDSHIP- AND THE
RELATIONSHIPS THAT I BUILT WITH
ALL OF YOURSELF. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MR OBERNOLTE AS WITH
SAID WE WILL MISS YOUR
INCREDIBLE QUESTIONS IN
COMMITTEE. THAT TRULY MAKE
POLICY BETTER FOR CALIFORNIA.
MOVING TO ATTRIBUTE FOR MISTER
GLORIA. MISTER MOON IS AGAIN
NOT WITH THIS WOMAN. PROVING TO
ATTRIBUTE FROM GLORY AND YOU
ARE TO BE RECOMMEND I'M GET
PHONE. FROM THE BACK.
MISTER
GORE YOU ARE SPARED INTEL
MONDAY.
MEMBERS ARE GONNA
CONTINUE WITH TRIBUTES TO OUR
TO PARTY MEMBERS WILL MOVE NOW
TO ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHRISTY
SMITH. LEADING A TRIBUTE FOR
MISMATCH IS ASSEMBLY MEMBER
JACQUI IRWIN IS THERE WHEN YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU SO
MUCH MISTER SPEAKER AND- AS JAY
MENTIONED EVERY YEAR OR- EVERY
EVERY TWO YEARS AT THE END OF
SESSION WE SAY GOODBYE TO OUR
COLLEAGUES AND ONE OF THE OF
THAT'S ONE OF THE HARDEST PARTS
OF THE YEAR BECAUSE SO MUCH OF
THIS JOB IS ABOUT RELATIONSHIPS
AND- OF FIVE WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO
WORK TOGETHER FOR A LONG TIME
ALL REALLY MISS YOU OF. MS MON
HAS BEEN AN INCREDIBLE
COLLEAGUE ALSO. BUT I'M-
HEARTBROKEN YOU BECAUSE YOU
WERE HERE FOR SUCH A SHORT TIME
AND- THERE WAS SUCH INCREDIBLE-
ENERGY BEHIND EVERYTHING THAT
YOU DID ALREADY. SO I AM RISING
TO HONOR MY FRIEND AND
COLLEAGUE- CHRISTY SMITH. NOT
ONLY DID WE SIT AND ADJACENCIES
BUT WE WERE IN ADJACENT
DISTRICTS AND- JUST A FUN FACT
ABOUT THE OF VENTURA COUNTY
VENTURA COUNTY EIGHT OF THE
NINE REPRESENTATIVES IN VENTURA
COUNTY WOMEN. PROBABLY HIGHER
PERCENTAGE THAN ANYWHERE ELSE
IN THE STATE AND UNFORTUNATELY-
MS SMITH IS LEAVING AND- I'M
NOT SURE WHO'S GONNA BE TAKING
YOUR SPOT THERE BUT IT WAS- YOU
WERE THE ONE THAT REALLY FOUGHT
FOR THAT SEAT I MET CHRISTIE.
WHEN SHE WAS RUNNING FOUR YEARS
AGO FOR THE STATE ASSEMBLY AND
I'VE NEVER MET ANYBODY THAT WAS
MORE DETERMINED AND WORKED
HARDER YOU ARE JUST AN
INCREDIBLE DYNAMO YOU ARE A
FIGHTER AND WHEN IT DIDN'T GO
THE DIRECTION THAT WE WANTED TO
GO IN THAT ELECTION FOR TWO
MORE YEARS YOU FOUGHT TO GET
THE SEAT. AND YOUR CONSTITUENTS
ARE SO LUCKY THAT YOU
REPRESENTED THEM FOR TWO YEARS.
UNFORTUNATELY OF. I HEARD A
CONGRESS PERSON RIZ. AND BRIGHT
AWAY CRISTINA THAT SHE HAD TO
STEP UP BECAUSE THAT WAS THE
ONLY WAY TO REALLY HOLD ON TO
THAT SEATS- DUTY CALLED. AND
AFTER ALL THE EFFORT TO WIN THE
ASSEMBLY C. YOU ARE RUNNING FOR
CONGRESS. HE WAS ELECTED TO AN
AREA THAT HAS VERY SIMILAR
POLITICS TO THE POLITICS I HAVE
AND WE OFTEN TO SIT HERE AND
MOST OF YOU DON'T KNOW THIS BUT
WE PLAY COMMERCIALS IN OUR
HEAD. OR OUT LOUD ABOUT HOW
YOUR BILLS ARE GOING TO BE
RUNNING IN OUR DISTRICT. THE
ATTACK ADS THAT ARE GOING TO BE
COMING WE DO IT VERY SOFTLY SO
WE DON'T OFFEND ANYBODY BUT- I
REALLY AND ENJOYED THAT SHE'S
WORKED INCREDIBLY HARD. TO
REPRESENT HER DISTRICT AND TO
BRING RESOURCES TO OUR
DISTRICT. THAT SAID NOBODY ELSE
EVER HAD SHE'S HIGHLY DEDICATED
TO EDUCATIONAL ISSUES SHE
SERVED ON THE- NEW HALL SCHOOL
BOARD AND THE PTA. SHE FOUNDED
THE VALENCIA VALLEY
TECHNOLOGICAL EDUCATION
FOUNDATION AND SERVED AS ITS
FIRST CHAIR. BUT WHAT SHE'S
REALLY SHE'S JUST REALLY
PASSIONATE ABOUT IS MAKING
SURE. THAT OUR YOUNG PEOPLE ARE
OPTIMISTIC ABOUT THE FUTURE.
WHEN YOU HEAR HER TALK ABOUT
THE YOUNG PEOPLE THAT SHE
WORKED WITH. THAT HELPED HER
GET ELECTED. IT'S SOMETHING
THAT I DON'T HEAR FROM VERY
MANY OTHER PEOPLE ABOUT HOW WE
MAKE NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT
THEY HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY. TO
SUCCEED AND SHE HAS BEEN AN
INCREDIBLE MENTOR TO MANY YOUNG
PEOPLE AS A MATTER OF FACT HER
DISTRICT DIRECTOR. A VERY YOUNG
MAN IS RUNNING FOR CITY COUNCIL
IN SEAMY VALLEY AND ALAN. I
KNOW THAT YOU REALLY PUSH HIM
IN THAT DIRECTION. WHEN SHE
CAME HERE SHE JUST HIT THE
GROUND RUNNING AND PASSED SOME
VERY VERY IMPORTANT LEGISLATION
THAT TOOK A VERY LONG TIME HAS
THIS LIMóN CAN ATTEST WITH THE
BANKING LEGISLATION. NOBODY HAD
REALLY BEEN ABLE TO GET THROUGH
AND MAKE SOME OF THE CHANGES
YOU DID BUT YOU REALLY USE YOUR
EXPERIENCE TO GET THAT DONE YOU
ARE BRIGHT. AND FUNNY AND YOU
ARE REALLY GOING TO BE MISSED
HERE I HAVE I'VE ENJOYED. YOUR
KNOWLEDGE OF POLICY I'D LOVE
pHOME WE GET HERE AND COMPARE
NOTES TO MAKE SURE THAT WE ARE
THINKING THE SAME WAY. AND I'M
REALLY I'M REALLY GOING TO MISS
YOU BUT- I'M TO BE VISITING YOU
IN DC AS I'M SURE MANY OF YOUR
COLLEAGUES WHERE ALL WILL BE
WHEN WERE LOBBYING YOU FOR
CALIFORNIA. AND GOOD LUCK AND
THANK YOU FOR ALL THE
CONTRIBUTIONS YOU HAVE MADE TO
THIS BODY. THANK YOU MISERABLE
HIS DARK HAIR AND YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR TRIBUTE TO
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS. THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER I AM SO HAPPY TO
HAVE THIS OPPORTUNITY TO RISE
TODAY TO CELEBRATE THE SERVICE
ASSEMBLY WOMAN CHRISTY SMITH. I
WAS THINKING ABOUT THE SPEECH
AND I WAS THINKING ABOUT HER
CHRISTIE'S DEPARTURE NEARS HER
TENURE HERE IN THIS HOUSE.
EVERY DAY THE CHRISTIE CAME ON
THIS FLOOR AND TOOK A VOTE AND
SAT N FRONT OF HER COMMITTEE
SHE ALWAYS ALWAYS TALKED ABOUT
WHAT HER DISTRICT WANTED HER TO
DO AND PUT HER COMMUNITY FIRST.
THIS COMMUNITY THAT SHE KNOWS
SO DEEPLY HAVING LIVED THERE
FOR DECADES RAISING HER GIRLS
THERE AND SERVING ON THEIR
LOCAL SCHOOL BOARD. AND SO WHEN
THE CALL CAME. THAT THEY NEEDED
HER TO RUN FOR OFFICE IN
WASHINGTON. SHE PUT COUNTRY
OVER SELF AND DECIDED TO RUN
FOR THAT OFFICE. AND AS
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WHEN SAID IT'S
TOO SOON WE'RE NOT READY TO
LOSE YOU CHRISTY. BUT WE'RE SO
GRATEFUL FOR ALL THAT YOU HAVE
DONE HERE ON THE SCREEN CARPET
IN IN THIS BUILDING. CHRISTINE
I MET ON THE CAMPAIGN TRAIL.
SHE A WIZENED SECOND TIME
CANDIDATES IN ME AS GREEN AS
THEY COME TRYING TO FIGURE IT
ALL OUT. AND THEN SINCE OUR
TEAMS HAD TO SIT IN THE
BASEMENT TO REGISTER AS VOTERS
FOR WEEKS BEFORE VICTORIES WERE
DECLARED. WE WENT THROUGH
FRESHMAN ORIENTATION JUST THE
TWO OF US. NOW I QUICKLY
LEARNED THAT IF YOU HAVE TO GO
THROUGH FRESHMAN ORIENTATION
WITH JUST ONE OTHER PERSON
CHRISTY IS THE PERSON YOU WANT
IN THE ROOM. QUIET SELF ASSURED
WAYS MAKE FOR THE PERFECT
ORIENTATION PARTNER. QUESTIONS
WERE ON POINT CLICK AND THERE
WEREN'T TOO MANY OF THEM. WE
BECAME FAST FRIENDS PICKING OUR
CHIEF TOGETHER THAT WEEK
CELEBRATING MILESTONES IN OUR
OFFICES AND FIGHTING FOR THE
LEGISLATION AND IS- ASSEMBLY
MEMBER LIMON SAID TRYING TO
FIGURE OUT HOW TO GET THESE
HARD BILLS THROUGH THIS
BUILDING. YOU HAVE ACCOMPLISHED
MORE IN YOUR TWO YEARS HERE
THAN MOST CONGRESS PEOPLE HAVE
IN A DECADE. YOU PASSED BILLS
PROTECTING OUR STUDENTS FROM
SEXUAL HARASSMENT AND EXPANDING
THEIR ACCESS TO RESOURCES. YOU
WROTE POLICY THAT WILL HOLD
CALIFORNIA CHARTER SCHOOLS
ACCOUNTABLE AND EXPANDED
RESOURCES FOR INJURED CHILDREN.
YOU ENSURING HUMAN TRAFFICKING
VICTIMS RECEIVE THEIR JUST
COMPENSATION AND INDIVIDUALS
THE RISK OF LOSING THEIR HOMES
CAN STAY HOUSE. YOU STOOD UP
FOR YOUR VALUES AT EVERY TURN
MAKING SURE YOU PROTECTED THE
BUDGETS OF OUR STATE AND OUR
COMMUNITY. AND IF THAT ALL
WASN'T ENOUGH IN HER VERY SHORT
TWO YEARS HERE SHE ALSO
DELIVERED SO MUCH FOR HER
DISTRICT FUNDING AN UPDATE TO A
LOCAL COMMUNITY COLLEGE A FREE
CLINIC IN SEAMY VALLEY HELPING
A SENIOR CENTER. AND
ESTABLISHING A CHILD CARE
CENTER AT CSU CHANNEL ISLANDS
KNOWING THAT THIS WILL GET MORE
WOMEN TO GRADUATE FROM COLLEGE.
THE FIGHT FOR WOMEN'S EQUITY IS
ALWAYS TOP OF MIND FOR CHRISTY.
IN FACT YOU MAY NOT KNOW THAT
SHE IS THE ASSEMBLY WOMAN. NOT
ASSEMBLY MEMBER. AND SHE
EXPLAINED TO ME THAT SHE WANTS
TO BE CALLED ASSEMBLY WOMAN
BECAUSE- IF YOU LOOK AROUND
THERE AREN'T AS MANY OF US AS
THERE ARE SIMPLY MEANT. AND SO
ONCE WE'RE EQUAL WE CAN ALL THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS BUT UNTIL THEN
SHE'S AN ASSEMBLYWOMAN. YOU
FINISH A TROOPS GIRL. AND THEN
YOU SIR YOUR CAN. AND YOU WILL
CONTINUE. TO SERVE YOUR
COMMUNITY IN VALUABLE WAYS AND
WE- KNOW THAT. FOR WOMEN OF HOW.
AND NOW THE GREAT. CHRIS I WILL
MISS NOT ONLY ARE. BUT YOUR
GUIDANCE ON THINGS. I MEAN
STILL CALL YOU BE WARNED- AND
YOUR QUICK WIT. MANY PEOPLE IN
THIS FOR MAKING BE AS QUIET BUT
THEY JUST HAVEN'T HEARD IT. I
KNOW THAT YOU. ALL OF US WILL
CONTINUE TO FIGHT FOR THE
PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA. WE WISH
YOU THE BEST OF LUCK WE WILL
MISS YOU SO. AND WE KNOW WE'LL
SEE YOU BACK HERE LEADING
SACRAMENTO SUNDAY. THANK YOU
SOMEONE ABOUT. ASSEMBLY WOMAN
SMITH. YOU LIKE TO MAKE SOME
COMMON. THANK YOU ALL- I ECHO
THE SENTIMENTS OF MY FELLOW
COLLEAGUES WHO FIND THEMSELVES
OF DEPARTING BUT WITH WITH ONE
CAVEAT- I DID NOT ANTICIPATE MY
ASSEMBLY EULOGY TO COME SO
SOON- BUT THE INTERNET LIKE
POLITICS CAN BE A REALLY CRAZY
WILD RIDE. AND SO HERE I AM BUT
IT HAS BEEN THE PRIVILEGE OF A
LIFETIME. TO SERVE NOT ONLY MY
CONSTITUENTS FORTY MILLION
CALIFORNIANS BUT TO SERVE WITH
EACH OF YOU. WHO BRINGS WITH
YOU YOUR OWN UNIQUE PERSPECTIVE
DEVELOPED FROM YOUR DISTRICT
FROM YOUR SERVICE. IN PRIOR
BODIES FROM THE WORK THAT
YOU'VE DONE THAT BROUGHT YOU
ALL TO THIS PLACE SO THAT WE
CAN ALL WORK TOGETHER ON BEHALF
OF CALIFORNIANS. I HAVE LEARNED
SOME AAZING THINGS WITH YOU I
HAVE SEEN ACTS OF POLITICAL
HEROISM AND DETERMINATION THAT
ASTONISHED ME. FROM OUR
COLLEAGUE IN SAN DIEGO- WITH
HER LANDMARK BILL TO COLLEAGUES
WHO HAVE MOVED FROM PERHAPS ONE
POLITICAL PERSPECTIVE. TO
ANOTHER AND SOME OF YOU WHO
HAVE FOUGHT DILIGENTLY FOR
ISSUES THAT BROUGHT YOU HERE IN
THE FIRST PLACE. AND MAYBE YOUR
FIGHT ISN'T FINISHED YET BUT
YOU CONTINUE. I'VE LEARNED A
FEW IMPORTANT THINGS. ONE
APPRECIATE YOUR STAFF BECAUSE
LITERALLY WE CAN'T DO THIS WORK
WITHOUT THEM SOMETIMES WHERE
THE IDEA AND THERE THE
EXECUTION. SO I WOULD SAY THANK
YOU SO MUCH VERY DEEPLY TO MY
ENTIRE STAFF MY SACRAMENTO TEAM
MY DISTRICT TEAM. MY SACRAMENTO
TEAM WILL BE LOOKING FOR HOMES
AND THEY ARE ALL WONDERFUL
AMAZING TALENTED GIFTED PEOPLE
PLEASE TAKE IN. IF YOU HAVE
AROUND. MY DISTRICT TEAM HAS
BEEN PHENOMENAL IN PART OF OUR
SUCCESS WAS JUST BEING IN THE
COMMUNITY BEING ACCESSIBLE
LITERALLY BEING AT EVERYTHING
IF THERE WAS A RIBBON CUTTING
FOR A DOG GROOMERS WE WERE
THERE THERE WAS A CHAMBER
MEETING WE WERE THEIR
NEIGHBORHOOD COUNCILS. WE WERE
THERE. THAT'S REALLY WHAT THIS
SERVICE SHOULD BE ABOUT. IT IS
EQUAL PARTS WHAT WE DO HERE IN
THIS ROOM ON BEHALF OF ALL. BUT
WHAT WE SERVE. TO OUR
COMMUNITY. CAN BE SO MUCH MORE
MEANINGFUL. SOFTENS THAT OUR
GREATEST FEAR OF INFLUENCES
THOSE IMMEDIATELY AROUND US AND
I LEARN FROM ALL OF YOU TO
EMBRACE THAT ROLE AS WELL AND
DIVE RIGHT IN. I LEARNED NEVER
TO TAKE A VOTE YOU CAN'T
DEFEND. SO I NEVER WALKED OFF
THIS FLOOR NOT THINKING IN MY
HEAD THERE'S GOING TO BE A
REPORTER OUTSIDE THE DOOR
ASKING ME WHY. AND I DEVELOPED
THAT. BEFORE I TOOK EVERY
SINGLE VOTE. AND SOME OF YOU
WERE VERY HELPFUL. IN YOUR
WORDS IN YOUR GUIDANCE IN YOUR
INSPIRATION IN YOUR
UNDERSTANDING OF WHAT. YOUR
BILL MEANT WHAT SOMEONE ELSE'S
BILL MEANT WHAT THE UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES MIGHT BE WHAT THE
REAL COSTS. MIGHT BE. AND HOW
WE COULD ALL WORK TO LEAVE THIS
ROOM. KNOWING THAT WE HAD TAKEN
ABOUT WE ARE PROUD OF. I
LEARNED A RIGHT BILLS. AND
ADVOCATE FOR BILLS. THAT I WAS
PROUD OF. WHERE THE WORK WAS
MEANINGFUL. AND ALTHOUGH I'VE
BEEN HERE A SHORT TIME I AM
PROUD OF EVERY SINGLE PIECE OF
LEGISLATION. THAT I PUT FORWARD
AND WAS PRIVILEGED TO HAVE
SIGNED. BUT I ALSO LEARNED. NOT
TO WASTE MY TIME. AT THE
MICROPHONE. AND I'VE STRUGGLED
OVER THIS MOMENT OVER WHAT TO
SAY TO NOT HAVE IT BE TRITE.
AND TO HAVE IT BE MEANINGFUL.
BUT WHAT I HAVE LEARNED. MOST
FROM THIS BRAND AND WHY
EXPERIENCE THAT I AM SO PROUD
OF IS THAT IN CALIFORNIA IN
DO THINGS WELL AND IT MADE IT
SO EASY FOR ME TO REPRESENT MY
SERVICE WHEN I WAS OUT IN THE
COMMUNITY. WE HAVE BEEN THE
NATION'S LEADERS ON CLIMATE
CHANGE NOW WE'RE GETTING THERE
ON HOUSING AND PROTECTING OUR
COAST ON PROTECTING WORKERS. IN
THIS STATE WE DO GOVERNMENT
WELL WE HAVE A RAINY DAY FUND
WE DO BI PARTISANSHIP WELL HERE.
AND THAT'S A LESSON NOW THAT
NEEDS TO BE CARRIED FORTH TO
THE REST OF THE COUNTRY. SO I
WAS PRIVILEGED TO COME INTO A
SYSTEM THAT WAS ALREADY WORKING
YOU GUYS WERE ALREADY PROOF OF
CONCEPT. THAT WE COULD DO THIS
AND THAT CALIFORNIA HAS LED THE
WAY. BUT NOW CALIFORNIA HAS ONE
MORE GREAT CHALLENGE. AS WE SEE
THIS COUNTRY PARTICULARLY IN
THIS POLITICAL CYCLE NEARLY
TORN ASUNDER BY THE POLITICS OF
OTHER ISM. END OF FEAR. IT HAS
TO BE CALIFORNIA THAT STANDS UP
AND SAYS WE KNOW HOW TO DO THIS
OUR CITIES OUR SUBURBS ARE
NEIGHBORHOODS LOOK LIKE WHAT
THE FUTURE OF THIS COUNTRY WILL
BE. RACIALLY RELIGIOUSLY
ECONOMICALLY DIVERSE. YET WE
KNOW HOW TO GOVERN AND CREATE
SYSTEMS TO PROVIDE EQUITY. IN
SUPPORT AND CARING AND
COMPASSION YES WE HAVE MORE
WORK HERE TO DO IN CALIFORNIA
STILL. BUT WE HAVE BEEN AND WE
MUST CONTINUE TO BE. THE BEACON
OF LIGHT ON ALL OF THOSE
IMPORTANT ISSUES THIS COUNTRY
IS DEPENDING ON THAT. TO BE
PROUD OF THE WORK THAT WE
CONTINUE TO DO. IN SUPPORTING
EVERY PEOPLE. REGARDLESS OF
INCOME. SKIN COLOR. IMMIGRATION
STATUS EMPLOYMENT STATUS
HOUSING STATUS. WE KNOW HOW TO
DO THAT WORK BECAUSE THAT'S
WHAT CALIFORNIA LOOKS LIKE
THESE ARE THE PEOPLE WE ALREADY
SERVE WE HAVE TO CONTINUE TO DO
IT WITH PRIDE. AND LEAD THE
WAY. SO IT HAS BEEN A PRIVILEGE
TO DO THAT WORK WITH YOU FOR
SUCH A SHORT TIME. BUT WHEN I'M
SUCCESSFUL IN NOVEMBER MY
DOORS- OPEN AND LET'S CONTINUE
TO DO GREAT THINGS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY. WOMAN SET
YOUR COMMENTS.
MEMBERS WE WILL
NOW MOVE TO ATTRIBUTE FOR
MISTER KANSEN CHU. WE WILL
BEGIN WITH MISS GONZALES
GONZALES ARE RECOGNIZED. I
CAN'T SEND YOU KNOW I WAS THE-
HONORED MOST SURPRISED WHEN I
GOT THE CALL TO ASK IF I WOULD
DO YOUR TRIBUTE. AND THEN I
REALIZED IT WAS REALLY BECAUSE
A DAISY NOT HERE RIGHT. SO FOR
THOSE OF YOU WHO DON'T I'M
JOKING OF COURSE THOSE OF YOU
WHO DON'T KNOW KANSEN IS BETTER
HALF- I'VE HAD SUCH AN
OPPORTUNITY TO NOT ONLY GET TO
KNOW KANSEN BUT- HIS STRONG.
BRILLIANT WIFE WHO- IT'S I
DON'T THINK OF ANY OTHER SPOUSE
THAT I'VE BEEN ABLE TO GET TO
KNOW IN THAT WAY AND I REALLY
APPRECIATED. KNOWING BOTH OF
THEM. I AS SUPPORTING KANSEN
BEFORE I KNEW HIM. THERE WERE
TWO DEMOCRATS RUNNING YOU
USUALLY TRY TO STAY OUT OF THAT.
BUT HE HAD SUCH GLOWING REVIEWS
FROM PEOPLE WHO HAD WORKED WITH
HIM FOR SO LONG. PEOPLE IN SAN
JOSE IN THE LABOR COMMUNITY
PEOPLE IT SERVED ON THE CITY
COUNCIL WITH HIM. AND THEY JUST
SAID. KANSEN IS A STAND UP GUY
HE IS A GUY WHO WILL GIVE YOU
HIS WORD AND BE THERE. HE'S THE
KIND OF GUY YOU DON'T HAVE TO
LOOK TWICE. AND SAY ARE YOU
SURE. I THINK IN THIS. IN THIS
HOUSE AND IN POLITICS IN
GENERAL THAT'S AN INCREDIBLE
INCREDIBLE. ALREADY TO HAVE
SOMEONE WHO YOU'RE NOT CHECKING
BACK WITH YOU JUST KNOW KANSEN
SOLID. AND WHEN HE GOT HERE
PROVED TO BE TRUE. RIGHT AWAY-
WE ACTUALLY DIDN'T SERVE ON THE
LABOUR COMMITTEE BUT SOMEBODY
MIGHT BILLS WENT THROUGH THERE
AND I CHECK IN WITH KANSEN HE'S
A I'M FINE. AND HE'D BE FINE
NEVER HAVE TO CHECK AGAIN. BUT
THEN ONE DAY I HAD A BILL ON
THE FLOOR THAT IS. VOTED ON
HE'D BEEN FINE HE MIGHT HAVE
BEEN BEEN A CO AUTHOR ON. IT
WAS TOUGH IT WAS STUCK I WAS
TAKING MEASUREMENTS AND TAKING
AMENDMENTS TO TRY TO GET IT
WHERE IT WAS. SO THEN I WENT
BACK AND I THINK I HAVE THE
VOTES. WE SAT OVER THERE AT THE
TIME AND KANSEN WALKED UP TO ME
AND I'VE JUST GOTTEN TO FORTY
ONE AND WE'RE ABOUT TO TAKE A
BACK UP OFF CALL. AND HE SAID
OH I CAN'T VOTE FOR YOUR BILL.
AND I. WHAT KANSEN YOUR VOTED
FOR LIKE WHAT ARE YOU TALKING I
TOOK ALL THESE AMENDMENTS IT'S
ACTUALLY EASIER TO VOTE FOR
THAT NOW YOU TOOK TO ME
AMENDMENTS IT DOESN'T MEAN
ANYTHING ANYMORE I'M NOT GONNA
VOTE FOR YOUR BILL. IN I LOOKED
AT HIM I START LAUGHING HE'S
LIKE NOW NOW. AND THEN I WAS
LIKE OH MY GOSH I DON'T HAVE
FORTY ONE BILLS AND THEN OF
COURSE HE STARTS LAUGHING HE
THOUGHT THAT WAS THE BEST JOKE
EVER. GREATEST JOKE. FROM THAT
DAY ON EVERY DAY I HAD ASKED
KANSEN ARE YOU TELL ME THE
TRUTH BECAUSE LIKE I CAN'T
SPELL. BUT I SAW HIM GROW AS A
LEGISLATOR AS WELL AND- THIS
MAY SOUND PETTY BUT FROM THE
DAY I WAS ELECTED I REALLY
WANTED TO DO A TIME CHANGE
BILL. AS APPEARANCE I HATE TIME
CHANGE IN MY STAFF WOULDN'T LET
ME DO IT. THEY JUST SAID NO YOU
YOU KNOW. IT'S TOO BIG THERE'S
TOO MANY MOVING PARTS YOU CAN'T
CHANGE DAYLIGHT SAVINGS TIME
AND THEN ONE DAY OUT OF THE
BLUE KANSEN ANNOUNCES HE'S
GOING TO TRY TO TAKE ON
DAYLIGHT SAVINGS TIME VERSUS.
THE TIME CHANGE. SIZE A LITTLE
JEALOUS AND I WENT TO CAMP
ANYTHING YOU CAN BE MY CO
AUTHOR. OKAY GOOD WE'RE GONNA
DO THIS PROPOSITION WE HAVE TO
GO THROUGH ITS STILL WAITING
DON'T WORRY I'LL I'LL BRING IT
UP NEXT YEAR AGAIN- BUT- KANSEN.
ME SAYS I HAVE. A MEDIA. ON IT
SO YOU YOU GO TO THE TV I WANT
TO DO THE TV. NICE TO KNOW
KANSEN IT'S YOUR BILL IT'S A
BIG DEAL THEY'RE GOING TO HAVE
A LOT OF MEDIA ON IT. NO I'M
WATCHED HIM GET. MORE
COMFORTABLE TALKING ABOUT THE
BILL ON TV AND DOING A GREAT
JOB OF SELLING IT SO MUCH SO
THAT THAT YOUR THE PROPOSITION
ABOUT TIME CHANGE WAS. IN FACT
THE MOST POPULAR PROPOSITIONS
ON THE BALLOT. ONE IN EVERY
SINGLE COUNTY SO WATCHING HIM
GROW IN AND REALLY BECOME A
LEGISLATORS COMMITTED TO WHAT
HE WAS DOING THE OTHER THING
I'D SAY A LOT OF US BEFORE COVE
ED UNDERSTOOD AS I WENT TO CAMP
IN EARLY ACTUALLY BUILDING A
TOLD ME M. HIS CAMPAIGN TAKING
A CHINESE FOOD AND I SAID I
DON'T EVEN KNOW I MEAN. I'VE
NEVER GONE TO REAL CHINESE FOOD
SO I ASKED KANSEN IF YOU TAKE
ME TO CHINESE FOOD AND HE SAID
OH YEAH YEAH I HAVE A PLACE.
BUT IT BECAME NOT JUST LIKE
EVERYTHING KANSEN DID WAS IT
JUST HE WASN'T ON TAKE ME HE
TOOK LIKE. SIXTEEN OF US TO
CHINESE FOOD IN IT BECAME A
TRADITION EVERY YEAR DAISY AND
KANSEN. WHAT WOULD BRING US OUT.
TO A RESTAURANT. AND WE WHEN
ASKED WHAT WE WERE EATING AND
WE WOULD JUST EAT REAL CHINESE
pWAS REAL AND EVERY TIME I'VE
ASKED HIM LIKE CAN YOU TELL ME
HOW TO ORDER THAT WHEN I'M ON
MY OWN HE REFUSES SO HE KNOWS
THAT I'M GONNA SHOW UP EVERY
TIME HE INVITES US TO REAL TIME
HE SAID. I AM. I'M GONNA MISS
KANSEN BECAUSE KANSEN PROVED TO
BE EVERYTHING EVERYBODY TOLD ME
HE WOULD BE. SOLID GREAT VALUES
AND I HAD NO IDEA I'D GET TO
MEET SUCH A FANTASTIC WOMAN IT
SERVES AS A REALLY HIS PARTNER.
AND AS A ADO O. DAYS IN KANSEN.
I'VE DONE SO MUCH GOOD FOR SO
MANY PEOPLE. AND WILL CONTINUE
TO DO THAT I KNOW WHEN KANSEN
BECOMES A SUPERVISOR. BUT I'D
SAY IF WE COULD ALL LEAVE THIS
PLACE WITH PEOPLE SAYING THEY
TOLD ME THAT YOUR WORD MEANT
SOMETHING. COMING AND THEY TOLD
ME THAT YOUR WORD WOULD ALWAYS
MEAN SOMETHING AND THAT YOU
WOULD BE HONEST. LOYAL CLEAR
AND ACTUALLY HAVE THAT BE DONE
AT THE END OF THE DAY WITHOUT
GRIPE THAT'S WHAT YOU'RE
LEAVING WITH EITHER PRECIADO
OUR FRIENDSHIP. AND APPRECIATE
FRIENDSHIP ARE SPOUSES HAD AND
OUR ABILITY TO S. CONTINUE THAT
AND I LOOK FORWARD TO A BEING
TAKEN TO REAL CHINESE FOOD IN
SANTA FE AS WELL SO THANK YOU
KANSEN CHU YOU WILL BE MISSED.
THANK YOU WITHIN THE HOUR DR
FOR YOU ARE RECOGNIZED. WHILE
MANY SURPRISES WORKING WITH
KANSEN PATTERSON WHO. WELLS.
THE VILLAGE SURPRISE WERE WITH.
THE BIGGEST ONE IS I FOUND THAT
IT WAS MY IDENTICAL BROTHER
THIS THIS'LL HAVE. BECAUSE HIS
IS A NEW SOUTH OF MY- AND WHEN
HE RUNNING I WENT TO I HE ASKED
ME TO GET GIVE HIM MY INTEREST
AND I AND TALKED TO A- AND I
REALIZE THAT. WE SHARED THIS
VALUES. AND IN FACT WHEN YOU
LOOK AT OUR VOTE RECORD THERE
UNLESS THEY- WHEN YOU LOOK AT
THE- PLACES. WE SPLIT THE SAY
OF FREE. THE SPLIT WHAT KNOWN
AS THE TRY CITY WHICH ARE THE
THREE SOAND WASHINGTON COUNTY
CANNELLA COUNTY. AN WE OF
COURSE ABOUT VERY PROGRESSIVE
DAM. VERY PROUD OF THE MAD AND
PER OF MY RELATIONS AND WE GO
TO BE IN THE TRI CITY. WE ARE
STILL TOGETHER LIKE SIAMESE
TWINS BECAUSE WE DO STAFF FOR
THIS THING BECAUSE WE CARE THE
PEOPLE IN OUR DISTRICT BECAUSE
WE DO CARE ABOUT THE PEOPLE IN
THE STATE HE'S GOING ON NOW TO
BUY BE A SUPERVISOR. SANTA
CLARA COUNTY. SUPERVISOR IS.
GREAT JOB BUT WHAT YOU'RE
DEALING WITH THERE ARE THE
PEOPLE WHO GET LOST PEOPLE WHO
ARE- LOW INCOME WHO NEED
MEDICAL HELP WE NEED. A
PASADENA VARIOUS TYPES YOU'RE
HELPING THE PEOPLE WHO ARE
GETTING LOST IN THE SYSTEM. AND
I KNOW CANCER AND I WHAT TO DO
HARD. AND I THINK HE WILL MAKE
A ACTUAL SUPER. I WILL MISS HIM
DEARLY. I WILL GETTING THE BEST
ROUTE. OUR LEE ARAMBULA MISS
CANCEL VERY MUCH THANK YOU.
THANK YOU DR PEPPER. TO KANSEN
CHU. THANK YOU MR- MRS VICKERS
FAN MEMBERS OF THANK YOU MY
TWIN BROTHER CORGI AND AS FOR
SANDY. TO SMALLISH WITH THE
KIND OF MY OFFICE AND INTERNAL
A SECRET. I REMEMBER THE FIRST
COMMITTEE MEETING AND I
ATTENDED WITHIN TH LABOR COMEY.
AND THERE AND THERE ARE SOME
MEMBER PRETENDING TO PAY.
TRYING TO GIVE. ALL THE
EMPLOYEE TO HAVE TO WORK ON
HOLIDAYS NEW YEAR AND CHRISTMAS
A DOUBLE PAID. YOU KNOW I WAS
SITTING THERE FOR AWHILE. SHE'S
MY LANGUAGE BECAUSE ONE I HAVE
THE FROM. I ALWAYS PAY MY STAFF
ON CHINESE NEW YEAR IN THE
BASEMENT MORE THAN DOUBLE
BECAUSE WE HAVE TO GIVE THEM
THE RIGHT THAT ENVELOPE AS WELL
THEY WHILE HE THIS REALLY
REALLY GREAT. AND THEN I TH
HALL HOW LAUREN A PRESENT A
BILL WITH SO MUCH PASSION.
AFTER TO MEET I WON TO MY- SHUT
THE DOOR. I TOLD MY STAFF IS A
NEVER MADE SURE THAT I VOTED ON
THE OPERA SIDE. OF PHILIP
LAWRENCE HOW THIS. SO I FEEL
THAT I HOPE I. MIGHT MIGHT
STAFF A CAB STRAIGHT. THROUGH
ALL THE FOR US. SIXTY I REALLY
REALLY BAD THE ON THE TO FOR
ALL OF YOU MANY OF. MAY KNOW.
DIE CAME CALL A PHONE. AS A-
STUDENT WAS TO AT FULL OF TAX.
YOU HAD DOLLARS TO MY P. AND
DOESN'T EVEN THE OTHER. AND TO
BE ABLE TO JOIN ALL OF HERE IN
THIS CHAMBER. TO DO TO WORK ON
BUSINESS THAT WOULD NOT ONLY
AFFECT HIM THE FORTY MILLION
CALIFORNIA NOW. BUT WILL ALSO
THE BILL FEATURE CALIFORNIA IS
SUCH A GREAT HONOR IT WAS SUCH
A GREAT EXPERIENCE. LARTER
LAURA MEASURE ABOUT MY SAW WANT
UP STAR VICE MY WIFE SOME MINE
THIS AGREE THAT THREE BETTER.
YOU KNOW SHE BEING WE BE MERRY
FOR FOUR YEARS OLD BEEN THE FOR
ME. IS THE- FRIEND AS A FOR.
AND THE LOVE OF LIFE. I ALSO
WANT TO THANK MY MODE. NINETY
EIGHT YEAR OLD. FOR HER
UNDERSTANDING. EVEN WITH A
LITTLE TIRING THAT I HAVE IN
THE DISTRICT. SHE NOW HAS TO
COMPETE WITH A GROWING THROUGH.
SO SHE'S REALLY REALLY. BEING
SUCH A WONDERFUL UNDERSTANDING
MURDER. SO BLAS. I'M DEFINITELY
VERY PROUD TO REPRESENT A VERY
DIVERSE COMMUNITY. 64% OF ALL
OF MY CONSTITUENTS. OUR
IMMIGRANTS. ANY GIVEN TIME
THERE'S EIGHTY DIFFERENT
LANGUAGES ARE SPOKEN. AND THERE
IS A HIGH PERCENTAGE OF ASIAN
AMERICANS. AND THIS IS A REALLY
GOOD OPPORTUNITY. TO REPRESENT
THEM AND TO GIVE THEM A VOICE
AT THE TABLE. I COULD NOT HAVE
DON THAT WITH ALL THE SUPPORT
AND THE TRUST. ALL OF MY
CONSTITUTIONAL. AND I HAVE THE
VERY PROUD TO SAY I HAVE LONG
THE LAST THIRTEEN CAMPAIGN.
FROM THE SCHOOL BOARD ALL THE
WAY TO THE ASSEMBLY. IN THE
LAST- TWENTY YEARS. AND I WANT
TO DEFINITELY HAVE EEN SHOT
OUT FOR. ALL OF OUR MEMBERS
HERE YOU KNOW FOR YOUR
FRIENDSHIP YOUR YOUR HIGHNESS
YOUR PATIENT. AND I JUST
LEARNED SO MUCH FROM ALL OF
YOU. AND THIS IS REALLY. VERY
REMARKABLE EXPERIENCE FOR ME. I
DEFINITELY WANTED TO THANK. THE
EARL THE DAILY BY CITY PERMITS
MR BONTA HEARING YOU KNOW YOU
IF YOU DON'T LIKE SOME OF THE
VOTE I TOOK. YOU CAN BLAME IT
ON BONTA HE MAY BE. AFSHIN THE
WRONG. OFTEN SO A LONG TO
SAYING THE SPEAKER. AND HIS
LEADERSHIP TEAM YOU KNOW. BLOOD
MAJORITY VOTE AND HAVE AN AN
AND ALL OF YOU AND THE LIPS AND
WHIPS MOREOVER WITH DOT TODD
GLORIA. AND. AND THE DATE THEY
WERE REALLY REALLY MAKING THIS.
A MEETING LOVER VOCAL REALLY
RELEASE. AS FOR SOMETIME IN
SOME OF THE JOKES HERE YOUR I
REALLY REALLY WANT TO TAKE THE
OFFER. TO SAY THE SPEAKER. AS
AND THAT AND HIS TO AND HIS
STAFF. IN I'M I'M VERY. AT A-
HIS LEADERSHIP WITH ALL OF THE-
ARE YOU WILL LEAVES CALLER. ALL
OF THE IS A TERRIBLE TIME YOU
THAT THE OF WHILE. AND DEPEND.
DEFINITELY WALA TO THANK MY-
BOTH CAPITAL OFF AND THE ALL.
ESPECIALLY MY CHIEF OF ANDY FAN.
SHE WAS THE REFUGEE YOU CAME TO
THE AND STATES OF THE YOUNGER
AGE. SHE REALLY. UNDERSTAND AND
EMBRACING THE DIFFERENT
CULTURES THAT WERE HAVING N
CALIFORNIA. SEAS BEING PUTTING
A 1100% OF- DURING THIS
PANDEMIC WAS TO THE SCHOOL AGE
CHILDREN AT HOME AND ALSO HAVE
A SICK MOTHER AND LOS ANGELES
SO ON A REALLY- THANKS AND ANY.
FOR YOUR YOUR- HARWARD YUR
YOUR YOUR INTELLIGENCE AND
KEEPING KEEP ME A STRAIGHT. ON
TRACK MOST OF THE TIME NOW ALL
THE TIME. IS I KNOW IS A VERY
CHALLENGING JOB FOR YOU BUT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH I WANT ALSO
SANK TO THE FLOOR STAFF FOR
HELPING US. YOU KNOW IN HE
PHOTO IN THE LAST- THE FIFTY
YEARS I WAS HERE. AND THE
SERGEANTS TO KEEP US SAFE. ALL
OF THANK THE JANITORS ALL RIGHT
THE JANITOR. WHO ALWAYS CAME
MEAN. THROUGH MY OFFICE WITH US.
AND OUR OF CLEAN AND HEALTHY. I
WILL MISS SO MANY THINGS IN
THIS PLACE. AND I REALLY OR
CHERISH A RELATION I HAVE BILL.
AT THE L. AND THE KINDNESS OF
MANY WILL HAVE SHOWN TO ME. I
WANT TO DO. I WANT TO ASK YOU
TO REMEMBER ME. AS THE. YOUNG
GRADUATE STUDENT. YOU KNOW I DO
DRESS LIKE YUBA- TELL WHO CAME
HERE. WITH NOTHING BUT AS
REALLY NOTHING. I WANT YOU TO
OPEN YOUR ARMS TO THOSE
NEWCOMERS. BECAUSE YOU YOU MAY
NOT KNOW SOMEDAY THEY COULD BE
YOUR COLLEAGUE. SO I'M AND ALSO
WANTED TO REMIND YOU TO SWITCH
O'CLOCK IN NOVEMBER. I'M COUNTY
ON J. WHO GO TO THE GOOGLE
CONGRESS AND MAKE THAT A
UNIFORM TIME ZONE CHANGE AND
I'M CON CON ALERT ENOUGH TO PUT
AVAIL THROUGH AGAIN. SO I DON'T
HAVE TO A CHANGE A BACK AND-
ANYWAY IS REALLY AGREE HONOR
SERVE WITH ALL OF YOU. AND TO
ALL THOSE WHO ARE OUTGOING
MEMBERS NO LONGER WISH THEM ALL
THE BEST OF LUCK. AND A TOLD
GLORIA HERE. YOU KNOW HIS BEING
WHIP. YOU KNOW YOU I WILL HAVE
YOUR AS OF WITH YOU KNOW JUST
CALLING ON TO THE ON THE- I
WILL NEVER GIVE UP THAT
POSITION TO RUN FULL SUPER ALL
THE SHORT DRIVE MAYOR. BUT I
WANT TO THE A VAST FLUFF. AND
THE- THANK VERY MUCH DESERVED
BEING ON. IT AND NOW LAW THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR- THANK
YOU. THANK YOU MISTER CHU I
KNOW WE'LL MISS YOU HEREWITH
THE BAY AREA CAUCUSES HAPPY
WILL CONTINUE TO SERVE ALONG
THANK YOU.
OKAY. MAZING. YEAH.
OKAY YEAH. YEAH.
MEMBERS.
MEMBERS I'D ANNOUNCEMENT THE
RULES COMMITTEE WILL BE MEETING
IN ROOM FORTY TWO OH TWO RIGHT
NOW SO HE SAID ON THE RULES
MANY PLEASE HAD UP.
TO FORTY
TWO OH TWO. MEMBERS PLEASE
RETURN SO FAR WE HAVE BUSINESS.
THAT WE NEED TO RETURN TO
MEMBERS PLEASE RETURN TO THE
ASSEMBLY FLOOR. WE CAN COMMENCE
BUSINESS.
MISTER CALDERON YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER THERE IS A RULES
COMMITTEE RESOLUTION AT THE
DESK TO SUSPEND THE JOINT RULES
TO ALLOW ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CERVANTES TWO DOT LATE
AMENDMENTS I ASKED THAT WE TAKE
UP THE RESOLUTION NOW. CLERK
WILL READ. RESULT FROM THE
JOINT RULES SIXTY ONE B.
SEVENTEEN BE SUSPENDED TO
PERMIT SENATE BILL FOURTEEN
FORTY SEVEN TO BE TAKEN UP FOR
THE PURPOSE OF CONSIDERING
AMENDMENTS. MEMBERS THIS
RESOLUTION SUSPENDS THE DOOR
RULES AND IS NOT DEBATABLE
REQUIRES FIFTY FOUR VOTES THE
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE. ALL
MEMBERS OF THEIR TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS IS VERY VOCAL. ALL
MEMBERS OF THE USER TO VOTE.
MISTER. THE CIRCLE. ALL.
MEMBERS VOTED THIRD VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS THIRTY DESERVE A.
WELL
CLOSE THE ROLE IN TELLING VOTE
HIGHS FIFTY FOUR NO ZERO THE
RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED THE RULES
ARE SUSPENDED. MISTER CALDERON
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED AGAIN THANK
YOU MADAM SPEAKER I REQUEST
UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO ORDER ITEM
A THIRTEEN S. B. TWENTY NINE
DORADO TO THE THIRD READING
FILE. WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH
SHALL BE THE ORDER.
WE WILL
TAKE UP ITEM FIFTY ONE FOR
PURPOSES OF AMENDMENTS SB
FOURTEEN FORTY SEVEN THE CLERK
WILL READ. SENATE BILL FOURTEEN
FORTY SEVEN WITH AMENDMENTS BY
SOME MEMBERS OF ARTISTS. MISTER
ROGERS YOU ARE RECOGNIZED IN
THE REAR CHAMBER FOR PURPOSES
OF AMENDMENTS. MADAM SPEAKER
MEMBERS TODAY PRESENTING
AMENDMENTS TO SENATE BILL
FOURTEEN FORTY SEVEN ON BEHALF
OF SENATOR BRADFORD AND CENTER
KABBADI KABBADI AT ALL. THESE
AMENDMENTS ESTABLISH A NEW
CAPTAIN ALLOCATED TAX CREDIT
FOR SMALL BUSINESSES. IN ORDER
TO QUALIFY FOR THE TAX CREDIT
THE SMALL BUSINESS MUST
DEMONSTRATE. THAT IT HAD A NET
INCREASE IN JOBS WHEN COMPARING
EMPLOYMENT IN THE SECOND
QUARTER OF TWENTY TWENTY WITH
EMPLOYMENT DURING THE FIVE
MONTH PERIOD. I DO I WANT TO
NOVEMBER THIRTIETH TWENTY
TWENTY. THE VALUE OF THE TAX
CREDIT IS ONE THOUSAND FOR
ADDITIONAL EMPLOYEE FOR THE
MAXIMUM OF A HUNDRED THOUSAND
PER SMALL BUSINESS TAXPAYERS.
THE SMALL BUSINESSES MAY USE
THEIR TAX CREDIT TO OFFSET
PERSONAL OR CORPORATE INCOME
TAX LIABILITY. OR ITS SALES AND
USE TAX LIABILITY TO QUALIFY
FOR THE CREDIT THE SMALL
BUSINESS MUST HAVE HAD A
HUNDRED OR FEWER EMPLOYEES IN
TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN. AND
EXPERIENCE AT LEAST 50% LOSS OF
REVENUES DURING THE SECOND
QUARTER OF TWENTY TWENTY. THESE
QUALIFICATIONS ARE THE SAME
CRITERIA USE AT THE FEDERAL
LEVEL FOR RECEIVING A MORE
GENEROUS PAYROLL TAX CREDIT.
COLLEAGUES I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR VOTE ON THESE
AMENDMENTS SO THAT THEY CAN BE
SENT BACK TO PRINCE OUR PRINT
TO BRING. HIM BACK ON FILE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MESS
AROUND QUE. WITH OBJECTION WE
WILL TAKE A VOTE ON THESE AND
ALL IN FAVOR SAY AYE. ALL
OPPOSED SAY NO. THE AYES HAVE
IT THE AMENDMENTS ADOPTED OUT
TO PRINT AND BACK ON FILE.
MEMBERS IN THE ABSENCE OF
OBJECTION WE WILL NOW MOVE TO
THE PREVIOUSLY ANNOUNCED
ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY. ALSO
WITHOUT OBJECTION FORM CALL
WILL BE LIFTED. MEMBERS PLEASE
TAKE YOUR SEATS OR TAKE YOUR
CONVERSATIONS OFF THE FLOOR.
HERE.
MEMBERS PLEASE TAKE YOUR
SEATS OR TAKE YOUR
CONVERSATIONS ON THE FLOOR WE
ARE MOVING TO ADJOURNMENTS IN
MEMORY. MISS FRIEDMAN YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS I RISE
TODAY TO REQUEST THAT WE HAD
DURING THE MEMORY OF DEPUTY
DENNIS GILL AND HIS DAUGHTER
TIFFANY GILL. DEPUTY GILL AND
TIFFANY WERE TRAGICALLY KILLED
IN A TRAFFIC ACCIDENT LAST
MONTH. DEPUTY DENNIS GILL SIR
FOR TWENTY YEARS AND THE LOS
ANGELES SHERIFF'S DEPARTMENT.
HE WORKED MANY DIFFERENT
ASSIGNMENTS IN MANY DIFFERENT
STATIONS ACROSS OUR REGION FROM
PASADENA TO WEST HOLLYWOOD IN
THE PERCENT OF ALLEY. IN HONOR
OF HIS EXEMPLARY PUBLIC SERVICE
DEPUTY GILL RECEIVED MANY
COMMENDATIONS INCLUDING THE
MERITORIOUS CONDUCT MEDAL FOR
HIS DILIGENT PERFORMANCE HARD
WORK AND HIS INTEGRITY. DEPUTY
HILL WITH HUMBLE AND KIND
COMPASSIONATE RESPECTFUL AND
WELL RESPECTED BY HIS PEERS.
FELLOW OFFICERS AND THE
COMMUNITY. HE LEAVES BEHIND A
LEGACY IS A GREAT PARTNER
PUBLIC SERVANT FRIEND SON
HUSBAND FATHER AND SON IN LAW.
TIFFANY MADDIE GILL WOULD HAVE
CELEBRATED HER FIFTEENTH
BIRTHDAY THIS WEEK. SHE
ATTENDED HOLY FAMILY HIGH
SCHOOL IN BURBANK I WAS
STARTING TENTH GRADE IN THE
FALL TIFFANY PLAYED BASKETBALL
VOLLEYBALL I WAS ACTIVE IN
NUMEROUS CLUBS. SHE WAS A SWEET
HAPPY BEAUTIFUL GIRL AND
DAUGHTER AND WAS ALWAYS WILLING
TO HELP OTHERS HER GOAL WAS TO
BE AN ATTORNEY AND TO BECOME A
SUPERIOR COURT JUDGE. TIFFANY
WANTED TO HELP THE WORLD BY
BECOMING PRESIDENT SOME DAY NO
I KNEW THIS CHILD AND BELIEVE
ME WHEN I TELL YOU THAT THIS
CHILD HAD A LIGHT AROUND HER.
THAT IS RARE IN THIS WORLD. ONE
DAY IN PARTICULAR I WAS AT THE
PLAYGROUND WITH MY DAUGHTER WHO
WAS MAYBE FOUR YEARS YOUNGER
THAN TIFFANY. NOW MOST OF THE
TIME BIG KIDS DON'T REALLY WANT
TO PLAY. WITH TODDLERS. BUT
TIFFANY SAW THAT RACHEL WAS
ALONE. AND SPENT THE ENTIRE
TIME AT THE PLAYGROUND. PLAYING
WITH HER PLAYING LITTLE KID
GAMES WITH HER. AND THEN
AFTERWARDS ASKED ME IF SHE
COULD BABYSIT SHE EVEN CAME
OVER TO ME AND TOLD ME WHEN SHE
FELT RACHEL. WAS FEELING SAD.
SHE WAS TRULY A GLOWING PERSON
AND WHEN I HEARD ABOUT HER VERY
UNTIMELY. DEMISE I CAN TELL YOU
THAT I CRIED AND I WAS TRULY
SHOCKED. HER MOTHER LOUISE IS A
VERY SPECIAL PERSON AND- I
DON'T KNOW HOW SHE'S GOING TO
MAKE IT THROUGH THIS REALLY
DIFFICULT TIME OF LOSING THIS
INCREDIBLE CHILD AND HER
HUSBAND. BUT ARE THE
COMMUNITIES HARD AS WITH THIS
FAMILY RIGHT NOW IN THIS TIME.
OUR THOUGHTS AND OUR PRAYERS
ARE WITH ALL OF THEM. AND I
REQUEST REALLY REQUIRE
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST THAT WE
HAD DURING TODAY IN THE MEMORY
OF DEPUTY DENNIS GILL AND
TIFFANY GILL THANK YOU. THANK
YOU MISS FRIEDMAN YOUR AGAIN
RECOGNIZED YOUR SECOND IS
REMEMBERING. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS I RISE TO
REQUEST TODAY THAT WE HAD
DURING TODAY'S SESSION THE
MEMORY OF A LONG TIME GLENDALE
RESIDENT AN ICON OF THE ARTS
AMAZON SUPREME AND SOMEONE WHO
I AM VERY PROUD TO SAY WAS MY
FRIEND THE HOBBIT ROADS. BORN
AS PATRICIA LAURA ADAMS IN LOS
ANGELES IN NINETEEN FORTY NINE
AND RAISED IN PACIFIC PALISADES
SHE SET OUT FOR THE WORLD AS
QUICKLY AS SHE COULD. AND
ADOPTED VELVET RHODES HAS HER
NAME. AND ALSO ADOPTED AFTER
STUDYING AT THE ROYAL ACADEMY
FOR DRAMATIC ARTS IN LONDON. A
REALLY FABULOUS BRITISH ACCENT.
SHE VENTURED INTO SINGING IN
ROCK BANDS THEATER PERFORMANCES
AN OIL PAINTING BUT I ALWAYS
FELT THAT BILL WITH ENTIRE LIFE
WAS A PERFORMANCE PIECE. I
COULD NEVER TELL WHERE THE
PERFORMANCE LET OFTEN VELVET
BEGAN OF THE REAL VELVET
BECAUSE THE REAL BILL THAT WAS.
ABOUT LIVING IN THE ARTS
EXPRESSING HERSELF EVERY DAY
THROUGH HER ARTISTIC ENDEAVORS
SHE WAS ALWAYS SLIGHTLY TONGUE
IN CHEEK VERY REVOLVED. VERY
OUTRAGEOUS. HAD WITH HER
TOWERING HEIGHT YOU COULDN'T
HELP BUT NOTICE HER WHEN SHE
WALKED IN A ROOM. AND SHE
PLAYED ON THAT TO MAKE EVERYONE
AROUND HER SMILE. WHEN SHE
RETURNED TO LOS ANGELES HER
CAREER INCLUDED ROLES AND
SERGEANT PEPPER'S LONELY HEARTS
CLUB BAND. ROCKY TO THE ROSE
AND BATMAN FOREVER. HER LATER
CREDITS INCLUDE WRITING
DIRECTING AND PRODUCING
INCLUDING HER TWO THOUSAND
FIFTEEN DOCUMENTARY. VINTAGE
GLORIOUS GLENDALE ALTHOUGH IT
WAS ALSO DEDICATED TO COMMUNITY
SERVICE ACTIVE IN THE SUNRISE
ROTARY THE GLENDALE CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE AND THE GLENDALE
KIWANIS CLUB. BUT IT WAS HER
WORK IN THE ARTS THAT WILL BE
HER LASTING LEGACY. IN TWO
THOUSAND FOURTEEN SHE FOUNDED
THE GLENDALE INTERNATIONAL FILM
FESTIVAL. HOW WHEN I WAS ON THE
CITY COUNCIL AND SHE CAME TO US
WITH THE IDEA FOR THIS FESTIVAL
QUITE HONESTLY WE THOUGHT SHE
WAS A LITTLE BIT CRAZY. AN
INTERNATIONAL FILM FESTIVAL IN
GLENDALE. AND WE WERE ALSO A
LITTLE SUSPICIOUS OF HER AND
HER MOTIVES. AND SHE WAS
RELENTLESS SHE KNOCKED ON DOORS
AND POUNDED THE PAVEMENT. AND
MADE US ALL BELIEVERS. REMINDED
ME OF A MOVIE LIKE A MIRACLE ON
THIRTY FOURTH STREET. ONE OF
THESE HOLLYWOOD MOVIES WHERE
SOMEONE SAYS LET'S GO PUT ON A
SHOW WELL SHE MADE IT HAPPEN BY
FORCE OF NATURE AND I WILL TELL
YOU THAT FILM FESTIVAL BECAME A
MECCA. FOR ASPIRING YOUNG
FILMMAKERS FROM ACROSS THE
REGION. WHO COULDN'T GET INTO
THE MORE ESTABLISHED FESTIVALS
LIKE SLAMDANCE AND SUNDANCE.
SHE MADE A TRULY COOPERATIVE
WITH THE FILMMAKERS CONTROL
THEIR DESTINY AND TO SEE THEIR
JOY OF WATCHING THEIR FILMS
BEING. PUT ON A BIG SCREEN
WHICH SHE WAS ABLE TO DO. AFTER
THEIR FAMILIES AND THEIR
FRIENDS AND THE AMOUNT OF
PEOPLE WHO CAME OUT TO SEE
THESE ARE EFFORTS REALLY HARKEN
BACK TO THE- DAYS OF WHAT
HOLLYWOOD USED TO BE INVOLVED
HERSELF REALLY EMBODY THOSE
DREAMS OF HOLLYWOOD AND THAT.
IDEA OF BEING ABLE TO MAKE
YOURSELF INTO ANYTHING THAT YOU
WANTED TO BE THAT WAS VELVET.
SHE WAS A FORTY OF NATURE SHE
WAS A TRAILBLAZER. SHE LIVES
WITH HER FRIENDS AND COLLEAGUES
THE MEMORY OF A STRONG WILLED.
WOMAN WHOSE FASHION ENSEMBLE
FOR THE DAY WOULD OFTEN
ANNOUNCED HER ARRIVAL TO AN
EVENT. WHOSE PASSION FOR
GLENDALE IN THE PERFORMING
ARTS. AND HER FILM FESTIVAL
WERE RADIOACTIVE AND SPREAD TO
EVERYONE SHE MADE US ALL
BELIEVE. AND WHO BY NUMEROUS
ACCOUNTS WOULD NEVER TAKE NO
FOR AN ANSWER AND I CAN TELL
YOU THAT SHE NEVER TOOK NO FOR
AN ANSWER. I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST THAT WE HAD TO RUN IN
THE MEMORY OF THE LEGACY AT THE
LEGENDARY VELVET ROBES THANK
YOU MADAM SPEAKER THANK YOU
MISS FRIEDMAN MISS AGUIAR-CURRY
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR
GERMANY MEMORY. MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS. THERE BEEN A NUMBER OF
DEVASTATING FIRES IN NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA ALREADY THIS YEAR A
GROWING NUMBER OF FAMILIES HAVE
FACED THE LOSS OF THEIR
LIVELIHOOD THEIR HOMES AND
BUSINESSES AND EVEN THEIR LOVED
ONES TODAY I RISE TO TELL JUST
ONE OF THOSE STORIES. IS WITH
AN EXTREMELY HEAVY HEART THAT
WE ANNOUNCE THE PASSING OF
THIRTY SEVEN YEAR I. B. E. W.
TWELVE FORTY FIVE MEMBER STEVE
WINK. WHO LOST HIS LIFE AT THE
AGE OF SIXTY WHILE WORKING AT
THE ELLEN YOU COMPLEX FIRE IN
BACK OF BILL. MR WINK WAS
ASSISTING FIRST RESPONDERS IN
THE FIRE ZONE AT THE TIME OF
HIS PASSING. LOCAL TWELVE FORTY
FIVE BUSINESS MANAGER TOM
DASCHLE SAID. OUR DEEPEST
CONDOLENCES GO OUT TO MISTER
WINGS FAMILY HIS FRIENDS AND
COWORKERS DURING THIS
ABSOLUTELY GUT WRENCHING TIME.
RATHER WEEK WAS A TRUE HERO THE
MAN WHO DID NOT HESITATE TO
HELP OTHERS SAVE LIVES. EVEN AT
THE EXPENSE OF HIS OWN AND OUR
ENTIRE UNION FAMILY IS MOURNING
THE LOSS OF A LIFE TAKEN TO
SOON. MR WINK WAS A PROBLEM IN
FOR PG&E OUT OF THE BACK OF THE
YARD KNOWN FOR HIS DILIGENT
WORK ETHIC AND RESERVE NATURE.
AND IS A HIGHLY RESPECTED
MARLIN PLOIDY AND UNION MEMBER.
HE LEAVES BEHIND HIS WIFE KIM
AND THREE DAUGHTERS. MEGAN
HALEY AND LAUREN. BOB YOURSELF
FROM LOCAL TWELVE FORTY FIVE
SAYS EVERYONE WHO WORKED WITH
STEVE WILL TELL YOU THAT THEY
WISH THEY HAD A HUNDRED MORE
GUYS LIKE HIM. TODAY E HONOR
HIS SACRIFICE MOURN HIS LOSS IN
STATE SEN STRENGTH TO HIS
FAMILY. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MISS AGUIAR-CURRY MR KILEY YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER TODAY I ASKED TO THE
ASSEMBLY ADJOURNED THE SESSION
IN THE MEMORY OF DR BRYCE JUST.
DOCTOR. INTERNING WILLIAM
JESSUP UNIVERSITY INTO THE
TREMENDOUS COLLEGE THAT IT IS
TODAY. HE WAS BORN IN BY SALIA
IN NINETEEN THIRTY FIVE HIS
FATHER WILLIAM STARTED SAN JOSE
BIBLE COLLEGE IN NINETEEN
THIRTY NINE FOUR BRYSON WROTE
AFTER HIGH SCHOOL. WELL IT'S AN
AS A BIBLE COLLEGE PRICE MET
THE LOVE OF HIS LIFE SURELY JOE
HOLBERT. HE BECAME PRESIDENT OF
CENTERS A BIBLE COLLEGE IN
NINETEEN EIGHTY FOUR. AND
CONTINUED HIS EDUCATION WELL IN
THE ROLE EARNING HIS DOCTORATE
OF DIVINITY DEGREES FROM A COP
I INTERNATIONAL UNIVERSITY. AND
NORTHWEST CHRISTIAN COLLEGE. IN
TWO THOUSAND TWO. THE COLLEGE
UNDERTOOK A LARGE EXPANSION AND
ROCKLAND IT WAS RENAMED WILLIAM
JESSUP UNIVERSITY IN HONOR OF
RICE'S FATHER. AFTER HIS
RETIREMENT IN TWO THOUSAND TEN.
BRYCE BECAME A SOUGHT AFTER
SPEAKER AND FREQUENTLY
PUBLISHED AUTHOR. HE RECEIVED
NUMEROUS AWARDS FOR HIS
COMMUNITY SERVICE INCLUDING A
LIFETIME ACHIEVEMENT AWARD AT
THE SACRAMENTO REGION'S ANNUAL
MARTIN LUTHER KING CELEBRATION
AT CAPITAL CHRISTIAN CENTER IN
TWO THOUSAND THIRTEEN. BRYCE
BUILT JUST UP UNIVERSITY ON THE
PILLARSOF FAITH AND EDUCATION
WHICH ARE OF SUCH CENTRAL
IMPORTANCE TO OUR BROADER
COMMUNITY. IN THAT WAY HIS
LEGACY IS NOT ONLY FELT BY
THOUSANDS OF STUDENTS AND
ALUMNI BUT IS LEFT A LASTING
MARK ON THE CHARACTER OF OUR
REGION. HE IS SURVIVED BY HIS
WIFE JO ALONG WITH THEIR
CHILDREN GRANDCHILDREN AND
GREAT GRANDCHILDREN. MADAM
SPEAKER TODAY I ASKED OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSEMBLY
ADJOURNED IN THE ALL IN HONOR
OF THE MEMORY OF DR RICE JUST A.
THANK YOU MISTER KILEY MISTER
COOPER YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS TODAY I RISE TO GERMAN
IN THE MEMORY MY CONSTITUENTS
ISABEL STOFFELS HUNT GRANADA'S
PASSED AWAY PEACEFULLY ON JULY
SIXTEENTH. BORN IN BOONE IOWA
IS A BILL ATTENDED STATE
UNIVERSITY AT AMES IOWA AND
LOCALLY HERE AT SACRAMENTO CITY
COLLEGE IS A BILL ROSE TO
BECOME THE CHIEF FINANCIAL
OFFICER THE ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA LIFE INSURANCE
COMPANIES AQUICK YOUR CAREER
THAT SPANNED THIRTY YEARS. IS A
BILL IS ALSO THE MINISTER OF
ASSISTANT TOO MANY LETTERS
OFFICIALS HERE IN THIS BUILDING
WAS BELOVED BY MANY. IS THE
BILL AS A VOLUNTEER FOR THE RED
CROSS DISASTER RELIEF SERVICES
IT WAS A FOUNDING MEMBER OF THE
L. GROSS ST CATHERINE GREEK
ORTHODOX CHURCH WHICH IS IN MY
NEIGHBORHOOD. IS ABILITY STRONG
PROPER GENEROUS GREEK WOMAN.
WITH FIFTY DEVOTED TO HER
FAMILY. PLEASE JOIN ME THE
JOINING IN THE MEMORY OF IS
STOFFELS GRANADA'S. THANK YOU
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO ADJOURN
IN HER MEMORY. THANK YOU MISTER
COOPER MISTER SALAS YOU ARE
pSPEAKER AND MEMBERS I RISE
TODAY TO ADJOURN IN THE MEMORY
OF CATALINA. RELIABLE THEY WILL
GAIN A RESIDENT OF MCFARLANE
BELOVED WIFE AND MOTHER. AND A
TIRELESS ADVOCATE AN ORGANIZER
FOR THE RIGHTS OF FARMWORKERS.
AFTER PERSONAL UPHILL. FROM
CESAR CHAVEZ CATALINA AND HER
HUSBAND CARMINE WALKED OUT OF
THE VINEYARDS DURING THE
DELANO. GRAPE STRIKE FROM.
NINETEEN SIXTY FIVE TO NINETEEN
SEVENTY. OVER THE NEXT SIX
DECADES CATALINA WAS A
STEADFAST ACTIVISTS AND NEARLY
EVERY MAJOR UNITED FARM WORKERS
STRIKE MARCH BOYCOTT RALLY AND
DEMONSTRATION FROM BAKERSFIELD
TO SACRAMENTO. BORN IN NINETEEN
THIRTY ONE AND SHE WHILE I
MEXICO CATALINA UNDER FAMILY
IMMIGRATED TO EL PASO TEXAS
WHERE SHE MARRIED GOVERNMENT
WILL GAIN WITH WHOM SHE HAD TEN
CHILDREN. THEY MOVED TO CANADA
CALIFORNIA SETTLING IN NINETEEN
SIXTY SEVEN AND MCFARLANE. THE
COUPLE LABORED ëALMOST
AGRICULTURAL CROP. THEY WERE
WORKING IN TABLE GRAPES WHEN
CESAR CHAVEZ ASKED THEM TO JOIN
THE STRIKE. IN THE DECADES THAT
FOLLOWED BOCHNIA CATALINA
PLAYED A VITAL ROLE IN ALMOST
EVERY MAJOR PORN YOU HAVE W.
EVENT IN CAMPAIGN. AMONG HER
MANY EFFORTS CATALINA HELP
ACHIEVE UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE
FOR FARMWORKERS AND ENACT
CALIFORNIA'S LANDMARK NINETEEN
SEVENTY FIVE FARM LABOR LAW
GRANTING ORGANIZING RIGHTS TO
FILLED LABORS. AFTER A LIFE
DEDICATED TO ACHIEVING RIGHTS
FOR FARMWORKERS BONIOR CATALINA
PASSED AWAY FROM NATURAL CAUSES
ON AUGUST SECOND. AT THE AGE OF
EIGHTY EIGHT. SURVIVED BY HER
TEN CHILDREN ADELINO WILL BE
REMEMBERED AND GREATLY MISSED
BY YOUR FAMILY AND THE
COUNTLESS PEOPLE SHE INSPIRED
AND HELPED. THROUGH HER EFFORTS
FIGHTING FOR THE RIGHTS OF
FARMWORKERS PLEASE JOIN ME IN
HONORING THE MEMORY OF CATALINA
WILL GAIN BY TURNING IN HER
MEMORY THIS CONTENT POSSIBLE
THROW ME GOT. THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER. THANK YOU MISTER SALAS
MEMBERS PLEASE BRING THE NAMES
THAT HAVE TO BE PRINTED IN THE
JOURNAL ALL REQUESTED JOURNEY
MEMORY WILL BE DEEMED READ AND
PRINTED IN THE JOURNAL. LIVING
TO ANNOUNCEMENT THE SESSION
SCHEDULED AS FOLLOWS FRIDAY
AUGUST TWENTY EIGHTH FLOOR
SESSION PHONE CALL THE SPEAKERS
SATURDAY AUGUST TWENTY NINTH.
NO FOR SESSION- CHECK IN
SESSION SUNDAY AUGUST THIRTIETH
FLOOR SESSION AT ONE PM WE'RE
GOOD. ALL OTHER ITEMS MEETING
WILL BE PASSED RETAINED ON
MOTION SHALL BE CONTINUED
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
BUSINESS I'M READY TO ENTERTAIN
A MOTION TO ADJOURN. MISTER
SALAS MOVED IN MR BONTA SECONDS
THIS TASK IN THE JOURNEY TILL
SUNDAY AUGUST THIRTIETH TWO PM.